Das war's für heute.
So, auf geht's.
Exzellent Werbung. Was gab's für Werbung?
Raid Shadow Legends.
Ah, yes. Exquisite.
Ich hab' schon das Level-Capture-Bait-Video auf hier, guck.
Dice finally talks about Belfill. Das ist Jebait.
Der redet hier zwei Sekunden drüber.
Der redet jetzt, na okay, eine Minute im Kreis, wahrscheinlich. Und dann, ähm...
Kommt wieder irgendwas anderes.
100% Jebaited.
Wenn man dann Jebaited...
Ah, so. Ich bin wirklich gerade erst aufgestanden.
Wir sind auch noch ein bisschen früher, ne?
Guck, normalerweise bin ich immer erst um...
Ah, ich hab' vergessen. Mittags hat er gar keine ordentliche Uhr mehr.
Normalerweise bin ich ja immer erst so 10 oder 10.10. oder irgendwie so am Start, aber...
Oh, was ist das denn für ein Tolle?
Ah, PHP-Sourcecode hacked.
Erstmal schön mit Weeb-Build.
So muss es sein.
Aber das müssen wir uns nicht angucken. Das haben wir uns schon mal im Stream angeguckt, den PHP-Sourcecode-Jebait.
Ja.
Was sagen denn die Corona-News?
So unter... Och, ich will es gar nicht wissen, Alter.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Sag mal, checkt irgendjemand? Ich verfolge das ja nur noch so am Rande alles.
Geht mir mittlerweile, geht mir sonst wo vorbei, ne? Muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Aber...
Wie ist das jetzt eigentlich?
Also muss ich jetzt wegen der Ausgangssperre...
Muss ich jetzt eigentlich wissen?
Also exakt die Zahl, wie sie gerade bei mir ist und wie ist das, wenn ich beispielsweise von hier in ein anderes Bundesland fahre oder in einen anderen Kreis fahre?
Und wie ist das, wenn ich hier losfahre und der Wert ist drunter und ich bin weg und der Wert geht dann hoch?
Kann ich da nicht mehr heimfahren oder wie ist das so?
Ich blick's nicht, das ist mir zu... Das ist zu low-brain, Alter.
Da bin ich zu free-head dafür, das zu verstehen, Alter.
Ja, das heißt doch aber auch... Also nur, dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, das ist wirklich nur für high IQ.
Also sprich, die Leute, die Leute, die müssten eigentlich alle bei mir subscriben, dass die überhaupt die Chance haben, das IQ-mäßig überhaupt noch zu verstehen.
Also das weiß ich, das weiß ich, dass die Zahlen dafür entscheidend sind.
Aber heißt das im Endeffekt, ich muss da jetzt jeden Tag bei denen... Also was heißt jeden Tag?
Stündlich bei denen auf die Homepage gucken oder wie?
Und was ist, wenn ich gerade unterwegs bin, also mal angenommen, ich bin gerade in Frankfurt und die Zahlen gehen hoch, darf ich da nicht mehr heim?
Ja, man weiß es nicht, also keine Ahnung, oder stell dir mal vor, ich bin in Frankfurt und Geschäft...
Und das muss dann zumachen oder was ist das dann?
Tom FMZ, Dankeschön für die Prime-Subscription.
Jeden Tag, also wie gesagt, ich blicke nicht mal durch, ich blicke absolut null durch.
Ach, das Timeout nach sieben Tagen.
Also das ist quasi... Ah, ok, ok, ok, also das heißt, alles heißt, wenn ich...
Also wenn ich jetzt mal angenommen, hier Frankfurt-Hanau ist über 100 und wenn das dann unter 100 fällt, dann dauert es noch sieben Tage bis das Timeout ist.
Aha.
Alter, ich blicke noch mal durch, ganz ehrlich ist mir auch wurscht.
Scheiß drauf, ich bin eh nach 22 Uhr selten draußen.
Und wenn, dann muss ich wahrscheinlich auf die Arbeit.
Als Greifen tut sie ab drei Tagen. Ach so, ich dachte, sobald es über 100 ist.
Ok, das hätte ich mir auch mal in einem Video angucken können, aber ich ignoriere das mittlerweile alles.
Es juckt mich alles nicht mehr.
Also ich weiß, meine Mutter hat nächste Woche einen Termin, ich noch nicht.
Aber vielleicht... Ja, aber ich nicht, ich nicht, ich nicht.
Aber wir haben Leute bei uns, die müssen auf jeden Fall auf die Arbeit fahren, das weiß ich.
Auf jeden Fall in sieben Support-Stells und sowas.
Die müssen tatsächlich hinfahren nach Frankfurt.
Und da haben sie es jetzt auch schon so gemacht, dass die Besetzung reduziert wurde.
Dass einer von daheim quasi Bereitschaft machen kann oder das Telefon geht und der andere muss vor Ort sein, falls irgendwas ist.
Das haben sie schon ein bisschen reduziert, aber so ganz weg ist das nicht.
Ja, so sieht es aus, das Sauros Master ist am Start. Danke schön für den Sub.
Huge Subscription. Massive.
Naja.
Ehrlich gesagt interessiert es mich mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Ich ignoriere das alles.
Ihr wisst, ich ignoriere mehr oder weniger die halbe Welt aktuell, weil mir quasi die halbe Welt auf den Sack geht mit irgendwelchem Zeug.
Es ist ja auf Twitter schon wieder so schlimm, Alter.
Ich habe letztens den Fehler gemacht. Ihr wisst, ich habe ja meinen Twitter auf Andorra gestellt, weil die in Andorra keine Twitter-Trends haben.
Ich habe letztens mal den Fehler gemacht und bin uneingeloggt.
Uneingeloggt wieder auf Twitter Deutschland gegangen, Leute. Das könnt ihr vergessen.
Da ist wieder der Rage-Modus und die Empörung und das Rumgeheule absolut top.
Das ist wirklich die absolute Krönung wieder.
Die sind wirklich alle wieder nur am weinen, den ganzen Tag.
Es ist der Wahnsinn. Ich weiß gar nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht. Haben die Leute echt gar nichts anderes zu tun, als auf Twitter zu gehen und rumzuheulen den ganzen Tag?
Das ist doch gar nicht möglich.
Also das kann doch eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Die müssen doch irgendwas machen.
Als nur auf Twitter zu gehen und sich zu empören und rumzuheulen den ganzen Tag.
Das geht doch überhaupt nicht.
Aber anscheinend schon. Zumindest wenn man auf Deutschland in die Twitter-Trends guckt, ist das zu einem großen Teil so.
Ob das dann gut wäre, weiß man ja nicht. Man kann ja vieles vermuten, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ich weiß das genauso wenig wie du und du wirst wahrscheinlich auch nicht besser wissen.
Es ist schwer zu sagen, was wäre wenn bei der ganzen Sache.
Und das liegt ja zum größten Teil daran, weil man ja noch nicht mal nachvollziehen kann, ob die Sachen, die man gemacht hat,
in welcher Art und Weise die Sachen, die man gemacht hat, jetzt wie mit der Entwicklung zusammenhängen.
Das ist ja höchst umstritten.
Also sprich, zu welchem Zeitpunkt was passiert ist, was daraus resultiert ist,
das wird wahrscheinlich noch jahrelange Analyse brauchen, bis man sich da halbwegs einig ist.
Und ganz ehrlich, mir wurscht. Hauptsache, dass das richtig Gute ist an der ganzen Corona-Geschichte.
Ich habe weiterhin Dauer-Homeoffice. Rest interessiert mich nicht. Hauptsache Dauer-Homeoffice haben.
Geht mir auch so. Also wenn ich auf Twitter Deutschland gucke, ist vorbei. Ist vorbei.
Ich weiß jetzt übrigens auch, ich war doch letztens auf Twitter Deutschland im Stream.
Und da gab es doch den Hashtag, irgendwie alles zu machen oder so, gab es doch einen Hashtag.
Jetzt weiß ich, woran das liegt. Das liegt hier an diesem Video da.
Also nicht vor der Tagesschau, sondern weil irgendwie 50 Schauspieler sich über die aktuelle Corona-Situation ausgelassen haben.
Und das geht natürlich gar nicht. Da muss ich komplett ganz Twitter Deutschland drüber empören.
Was können die auch wagen, einfach ihre Meinung auf YouTube zu posten?
Das ist ja unten. Das ist ja, ne. Also sowas im Jahr 2021, die musst du gleich instant feuern alle.
Zumindest wenn es nach Twitter geht. Dann haben sich wieder alle wahnsinnig aufgeregt.
Zum Glück habe ich mir das nicht angeguckt. Hätte ich mich wieder aufregen müssen.
Ah ja. Quinn131, Dankeschön für 4 Monate Subscription.
Übrigens, gestern hatte ich die Impfgegner bei mir im Briefkasten. Soll ich euch das mal vorlesen?
Moment Leute, ich muss kurz das Bild aufmachen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch dieses Foto zeigen kann.
Äh, hier. Also. Also hier. Impfgegner. Hanau steht auf. Hanau steht auf.
Das Allianz Pro Grundgesetz hat sich bei mir im Briefkasten geschlichen gestern.
Warte mal, ich gucke mal, ob ich euch das uploaden kann. Das ist wieder...
Das ist auch Bane's Champ. Richtig Bane's Champ, Alter.
Warte mal, mal gucken, ob ich das irgendwie uploaden kripp, uploaden bekomme.
Post Image.
Richtiger Bane's Champ auf jeden Fall wieder.
Wartet mal hier, Post Image.
Aber ich würde, ich, beispielsweise, ich bin ja bei sowas, ich versuche da immer halbwegs neutral zu sein, ja.
Ich sagte, hey, ich will, dass die Leute mir das zugestehen, dass ich ihnen mein Zeug und dass ich mein Zeug frei erzählen darf.
Ich gestehe das denen auch so, dass die ihr Zeug frei erzählen dürfen.
Ich meine, ich muss es nicht gut finden, ja.
Ich muss es ja nicht gut finden, aber die können sich da mal, ich zeige euch das gerade mal, das ist wieder...
Ex, excellent Impfgegner, Stels.
Ok, ich versuche euch das jetzt mal zu zeigen.
Moment.
Ja, warte mal, ich finde das vollkommen ok, wenn man sich da drüber, kann ich das vielleicht auch nochmal sagen.
Ich finde das vollkommen ok, wenn man sich da drüber, wenn man da Kritik dran äußert.
Aber ich meine, es hört jetzt mal spätestens an der Stelle auf, wenn Leute öffentlich sagen, ARD schmeißt sie alle raus.
Weil dann ist, dann ist Ende mit freier Meinungsäußerung.
Also wenn du quasi um, also die nächste, die nächste Stufe wäre dann China.
Du musst um Leib und Leben fürchten, wenn du was sagst, was den Leuten nicht gefällt.
Und das ist natürlich nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Vielleicht möchten das manche gerne, ich weiß nicht.
Dann sind wir bei den, bei den China-Chinesen.
So, warte mal, hier.
Post, ich zeige euch mal die...
Die Impfgegner-Stellen, die sie bei mir eingeworfen haben.
Ja, guckt euch das mal an, warte mal.
Naja, das ist ja, das ist ja im Prinzip, das ist ja im Prinzip das Schöne.
Wenn er das sagen kann und trotzdem da keine Auswirkungen hat für seinen Beruf.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, das eine schließt das andere ja nicht unbedingt aus.
Da könntest du sogar eher, du könntest sogar eigentlich eher sagen, hey, also wenn man denn überhaupt von ausgeht, dass das der Fall ist.
Da könntest du sogar sagen, okay, dann Hut ab, dass er sich das traut.
Also ich hab's mir nicht angeguckt.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Kokona und Kokomata?
Das ist ganz einfach, das muss man wissen auf Twitch.
Das, Kokona, sind die Amis und Kokomata, das sind die Russen.
Das sieht man auch schon am, am, im Out.
So, hack, x, x hack, y, x.
Eigentlich für den Zap, also pass mal auf hier.
Exzellent, exzellent Impfgegner am Start bei mir im Briefkasten hier.
Also, Hanau steht auf.
Ja, Alter, das Platoon Musik, hört mal auf.
Das Platoon Musik, ich mag das Platoon Musik nicht.
Guckt euch, guckt euch das mal an.
Hoch, wait a minute, wo ist es hin?
Hier?
Hä, bin ich jetzt total 3-Hat, wo hab ich denn, ach da, ach da hab ich's.
So, also, wir sind alles, wir sind alles Laborratten.
Und so, wie gesagt, ich hab's nur mal fotografiert,
weil ich mir gesagt hab, kann ich euch ja mal zeigen.
Und ja, Übungen, dieser Flyer ist keine Werbung.
Rechtsgrundlage ist das Grundgesetz.
Jeder hat Recht, seine Meinung in Wortschrift und bildfrei zu äußern.
Aha, exquisite.
Aber gut, man, wie gesagt, dürfen so machen.
Meinen wegen, ich mein, ich muss die Meinung ja nicht teilen.
Ansonsten ist das Ganze natürlich schon reichlich übertrieben.
Vor allem, was ist die Alternative?
Weil ich da Corona haben, ist natürlich auch nicht sinnvoll.
Ich spiegel mich, ach so, die andere Seite gab's ja auch noch.
Moment, die andere Seite war irgendwie,
Kontergan ist sicher.
Da haben sie jetzt irgendwelche Sachen von 1960 ausgebuddelt.
Naja, wenn sie meinen.
Also ich hab von diesen Clips nicht wirklich viel gesehen.
Ich hab nur in ein paar reingeguckt.
Und manche, finde ich, waren offensichtlich übertrieben.
Also da wurde offensichtlich quasi das eine gesagt und das andere gemeint.
Ja, das ist ungefähr, wenn ich so sage, alter, der Twitch-Chat,
so nach dem, warte was, gibt's da ein gutes Beispiel.
Also man kann ja total übertrieben was sagen und damit quasi eindeutig das andere meinen.
So nach dem Motto, ich finde es ganz besonders toll, dass es so viele Pool-Streams auf Twitch gibt.
Sowas in der Richtung, da weiß jeder, was gemeint ist.
Da weiß jeder, ich mag eigentlich keine Pool-Streams auf Twitch.
Ja, und da kamen mir zumindest die paar Ausschnitte,
wo ich durchgeklickt hab durch die Videos,
kamen mir schon einige ganz klar in diese Richtung verstehen, ja.
Das Scam-Train ist am Start.
Ja, das Scam-Train ist zum Beispiel auch sowas, ne.
Ich sag das Scam-Train, aber in Wirklichkeit ist ja jeder selbst schuld, wenn er draufklickt.
Kann ich ja nix für uns.
Ist ja nicht so, als hätt ich euch gescampt zusammen.
Aber natürlich, wenn ihr Prime-Subscriptions übrig habt,
ich freu mich selbstverständlich immer über exellente Subscriptions.
Und nicht zu vergessen, dass natürlich der Chat-IQ wieder durch die Decke geht.
Da kommt wieder Pool-Stream jederzeit, jederzeit.
Kann jederzeit so halt sein.
Nächste Pool-Stream kommt mit dem Face-Reveal.
Benutzt du Home Assistant, worauf hast du es installiert?
Ich hab Home Assistant auf einer Low-Power-Intel-Plattform installiert.
Und zwar auf einem, ich glaub MSI ist es, oder?
Äh...
Ne, S-Rock?
Ich glaub, ein S-Rock-Bord ist das.
Sowas da.
Ja, auf so einem Board allerdings nicht exakt auf dem.
Ich hab eins, wo ein Full-Size-PCI-Express-Slot dran ist.
Aber das würd ich jetzt nicht mehr kaufen, weil da gibt's eine neuere Variante davon.
Intel-CPU-On-Board.
Ups, was hab ich jetzt angeklickt?
MonkaS.
Da.
Ich glaub, das ist die aktuelle Version von dem Board, was ich hab.
Was wir hier drauf sehen, ist natürlich ganz toll.
Ein Parallel-Port und ein serieller Port.
Also quasi die Schnittstellen, die man selbstverständlich 2021 dringendst benötigt.
Kostet 60 Euro oder so.
Ja, wünschen wir dir auch.
Hoff ich mal, Chet, ne?
Tamagot-shi-shi.
Ja, also das da mit den Big-Brain-Schnittstellen.
Ich hab mir das nur gekauft, weil es ein Full-Size-PCI-Express-Slot ist.
Aber man sieht's hier oben auch schon.
Jetzt machen wir mal Trick 17, Chet.
Chet, erkennt ihr, wie viel Fach USB das hier ist?
Anhand des Builds?
Wie viel ist das?
Man erkennt ja die Kontakte.
Das ist ein 16er-Slot, aber nur...
Postchamp?
Wer weiß es?
Zwei, korrekt.
Zwei.
Hab ich USB gesagt? Ich mein, PC-Express.
Keg-Wade.
Ich mein, PC-Express zweifach ist das nur Angebot.
Man sieht's auch auf dem Foto ausgerechnet mal gut.
Also normalerweise sieht man das ja auf den Mainboard-Fotos nicht.
Eins, zweifach.
Und es ist aber ein 16-fach-Slot.
Das heißt, du musst da nicht hinten dran rumsegen oder sowas.
Hab ich USB gesagt?
Ah ja, komm, boom mal hier.
Und da kann das schon mal passieren, dass man sich da verspricht.
Ist nicht teuer.
Kostet irgendwie 60 Euro oder so, zeig ich mal, ja.
Und mal Geizhals, wobei Chipreise ja aktuell eh.
Da hab ich eine 10-Gigabit-Karte drin.
In dem Slot.
Heute würd ich das ein bisschen anders machen.
Heute würd ich mir eine USB 2,5G kaufen, weil das reicht für das, was drin ist.
Aber 2,5G war vor eineinhalb Jahren, wo ich das gebaut hab, oder zwei Jahren.
Das ist schon ein bisschen her.
Haben wir hier im Stream zusammen mit ein bisschen rumgebaut.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig gewesen.
Welches OS?
Hä?
Welches OS ist irgendwie komisch, find ich.
Was ist komisch?
Ubuntu Server ist da drauf, 2004.
Ja, also einen Intel NUC hab ich mir genau aus diesem Grund nicht gekauft,
weil ich einen PC-Express-Slot haben will.
Also die Leistung reicht übrigens auch.
Ich mein, damit reißt du keine Bäume aus.
Ein Intel NUC ist je nach Ausstattung natürlich deutlich schneller.
Oder jede andere x-beliebige Plattform ist wahrscheinlich schneller.
Das ist ein Vierkern Low-Power-CPU.
Das ist jetzt von einem Celeron.
Früher waren das mal, glaub ich, Basis, sind irgendwelche Atoms.
Hat das Ding überhaupt NVMe?
Der hier, glaub ich, nicht, aber es gibt, glaub ich, Mainboard-Varianten davon mit M2-Slot, die das haben.
Die hier haben kein M2-Slot, weil das Ding nicht genug PC-Express-Lanes hat,
um damit auch noch zweifach PC-Express anzubinden.
Also muss man mal gucken.
Es gibt, glaube ich, auch welche mit M2, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die von S-Rock sind.
Nee, das ist nur WLAN. M2E ist WLAN, ne? Genau, da oben.
Es gibt von MSI noch welche und es gibt noch...
Hat der hier einen M2? Seht ihr hier irgendwas?
Ja, aber auch nur Wi-Fi.
Es gibt beispielsweise davon noch ein anderes Board.
Es gibt einen Odroid HC2, sogar HC+.
Das ist auch so ein ähnliches Board.
Und die haben...
Alter, was? Die Yoshi-Musik ist ja gerade wieder...
Die haben RAM und die haben auch einen M2-Slot für SSDs.
Muss man sich gucken, was man will. Die haben auch zwei Netzwerkanschlüsse dran.
Es gibt ein paar Boards mit dieser Plattform, aber für mich war das hier echt das Beste,
weil ich halt eine 10-Gigabit-Karte reinmachen will.
Man muss dazu sagen, die 10-Gigabit-Karte funktioniert natürlich hier nicht voll.
Also ich bräuchte vier PC-Express-Lanes, mindestens,
dass ich die halbwegs ausreizen könnte.
Und ich habe nur zwei, also zweifach angebunden.
Und...
Das muss dann auch schon eine halbwegs neue Karte sein.
Es gab ja auch früher welche, die 16 hatten und selbst nur PC-Express 1 konnten und sowas.
Muss man halt gucken, dass es eine passende Karte hat.
Aber es reicht dafür, ich kriege da irgendwie was um 5-6 Gigabit durch.
Wir haben es ja mal im Stream ausprobiert.
Das reicht dicke, mehr kriege ich von der SSD eh nicht runter da.
So, kostet hier aktuell 89 Euro.
Und normalerweise ist der Kram sogar, ihr seht es, das ist wieder hochgegangen.
Normalerweise ist der Kram, ich habe es euch nämlich...
Okay.
Ich hätte ja gesagt, es hat irgendwas von 65 ursprünglich gekostet.
Aber vielleicht war das die alte Variante, die ich hatte.
Oder vielleicht hat es auch 85 gekostet.
Vielleicht habe ich euch auch ein Mist erzählt, kann sein.
Aber 85 Euro finde ich ist echt ein super Preis dafür.
Du kannst damit alles machen.
Das Ding hat komplett...
Also die CPUs haben Krypto-Extensions im Vergleich zu einem Raspberry Pi,
der sowas nicht hat.
Würde das für Heimunterhaltung reichen?
Ja locker, locker, super.
Du hast eine halbwegs gescheite Onboard-GPU,
um beispielsweise Kodi 3D beschleunigt anzeigen zu lassen.
Das einzige, was du damit glaube ich relativ schwierig machen kannst,
sind 4K Filme on the fly transcoden.
Der Raspberry Pi 40bit hat keine Krypto-Extensions.
Vielleicht das Compute-Module, das weiß ich nicht, aber hat er nicht.
So und...
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also ich glaube 4K transcoded können schwierig werden.
Ich glaube der hat zwar Intel Quick Sync für solche Transcoding-Sachen,
aber ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das Ding das hinbekommt,
4K on the fly zu transcoden.
Aber ganz im Ernst, eigentlich braucht niemand 4K Transcoding on the fly.
Es sei denn, es sei denn,
man ist jemand, der permanent auf irgendwelchen komischen Tauschbörsen
sich Sachen in MKV mit komischen M-Coding runter lädt
und das dann in irgendwas transcoden will, was Kodi abspielen kann.
Fragt mich nicht, aber normalerweise braucht man das eigentlich nicht.
Und vielleicht geht das mit Quick Sync auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Zumindest das coole ist, die CPUs haben Krypto-Extensions, 4 Kerne,
die allesamt natürlich schneller sind als ein Raspberry Pi.
Also eine ganze Ecke schneller als...
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar mal Benchmark.
Ich glaube, das war irgendwie 6-, 7-mal schneller als ein aktueller Raspberry Pi, das Teil.
Also ist schon... Nee, wobei, nee, nicht ganz so viel.
3-mal, 3-, 4-mal schneller.
Es war auf jeden Fall eine ganze Ecke schneller als ein aktueller Raspberry Pi.
Also preislich ist das echt eine Alternative.
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen größer als ein Raspberry Pi.
Also ein Raspberry Pi ist ungefähr so groß hier, so wie hier unten oder so.
So groß.
Und das ist halt dann irgendwie 5-, 6-mal größer als ein Raspberry Pi.
Dafür hast du halt auch mehr Zeug drauf.
Du brauchst leider kurzen...
Wie heißt das Ding nochmal?
S0 RAM.
Also DIMM 0 RAM. Wie heißt denn das richtig?
Chat, Chat, da weiß das. Chat ist Hi-AQ.
Obscription-Chat.
Du brauchst kurze RAM-Riegel auf jeden Fall.
Aber so teuer sind die nicht.
Also RAM war ja eine lange Zeit ultra günstig.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das jetzt aussieht.
Wie sieht... Wie ist eigentlich so der...
Wie ist eigentlich so der Arbeitsspeicherpreis aktuell?
Warte mal kurz.
Schauen wir mal schnell.
DDR4.
Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal normalen.
Ab 32G.
Wir waren schon richtig. Oh, es geht doch immer noch.
Ist doch alles vollkommen in Ordnung.
130, 130G und 32G.
Das ist relativ günstig.
Das ist aber immer noch relativ günstig.
Guck mal, geht doch. Easy as fuck.
Hat sich kaum was bewegt.
Der ist hier mal kurz übelst explodiert.
Und jetzt ist er wieder unten.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der hier so krass explodiert ist.
Aber ansonsten ist der RAM-Preis vollkommen in Ordnung.
So.
Kurz-Chat-Beantwortung.
Ja, Grafikan und CPU-Preis sind übertrieben hoch.
Das...
Naja, also wenn du 4K-Videos rein CPU-mäßig abspielst,
dann ist wahrscheinlich auch ein 3700er da ganz gut beschäftigt.
Aber da sollte das eigentlich schaffen.
Das braucht halt viel, ne?
Also gerade wenn es 4K, 60Hz oder sowas, also 60FPS ist, das frisst ordentlich.
Also rein CPU-Decoding.
Aber man muss ja kein reines CPU-Decoding machen, weil du hast ja Quick Sync in der CPU und du hast eine On-Board-GPU, die sicherlich auch ein bisschen was übernehmen kann.
So.
Ja genau, da ist schon eine CPU drauf auf dem Mainboard.
Also du bezahlst 85€ und dann hast du alle.
Also was kannst du alles in Home Assistant... Was? Hast du alles in Home Assistant drin oder was ist alles steuerbar?
Ich würde es euch ja gerne zeigen, aber ich habe Schiss, dass ich zu viel liege, wenn ich mein Home Assistant zeige.
Wartet mal.
Nee, ich muss das in einem Video machen, ohne Scheiß.
Ich kann das jetzt hier nicht zeigen.
Ich habe da zum Beispiel eine Karte drin und sowas. Das muss ich erstmal alles wegmachen.
Ich mach da echt mal ein Video drüber.
Also ich kann dir aber sagen, was ich drinne habe.
Also ich hab so... Wobei...
Einfach nur vorlesen ist auch doof oder?
Das wäre schon schöner, wenn man das sieht.
Aber was ist das?
Oder das wäre schon schöner, wenn man das sieht.
Aber was willst du machen?
Also ich sage es euch mal ganz schnell.
Also ich habe einmal einen Müllkalender drinne.
Wo man sieht Biomüll in 12 Tagen und Papiermüll in 11 Tagen und sowas sehe ich dann.
Dann habe ich Außentemperatur, Luftqualität auf der Startseite.
Dann habe ich einen Status, wer alles daheim ist.
Dann habe ich die Zugverbindung nach Frankfurt.
Direkte Zugverbindung nach Frankfurt, ob es Verspätungen gibt.
Falls ich mal wieder Zug fahren muss.
Dann habe ich die Fenster.
So eine Übersicht.
Ob ich Fenster vergessen habe auf und zu zu machen.
Ob ich vergessen habe Fenster zu zu machen.
Dann habe ich die Tankstellen.
3 Tankstellen in der Nähe drin.
Mit dem aktuellen Preis und dem Aktualisierungsdatum.
Dann habe ich den Verbrauch vom ganzen Haus drinne.
Was gerade kaputt ist, weil mein Sensor verrutscht ist.
Dann habe ich einen...
Dann habe ich eine Anzeige Batterieladung.
Also dass zum Beispiel der Sensor am Eingang 13% ist gerade.
Und das Fritz-Thermostat hier oben 90%.
So dann habe ich Thermostate drinne im Wohnzimmer.
Ein bisschen die Steuerung für den Stop-Säure-Roboter drinne.
Status vom Fernseher drüben.
Lampen im Wohnzimmer.
Thermostat hier im Arbeitszimmer.
Schreibtisch.
Steckdose.
Im Serverraum den 3D Drucker.
Beleuchtung am Fenster an der Decke.
Von meinem Basteltisch.
Temperatur und Lichtsensor vom Kühlschrank.
Dass ich weiß ob das da irgendwas kaputt ist.
Dann habe ich den Bad drinne.
Fenster auf und zu machen.
Das Gewicht von der Waage.
Pepo-Fett.
Heizlüfter an und ausschalten.
Temperatur Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Anhand dessen kann ich das Thermostat regeln.
In der Küche unten.
Das Radio und Lade-Dings vom Staubsauger.
Wie viel das verbraucht.
Dann das Fenster auf und zu.
Im Keller habe ich die Kellerfenster.
Aktuellen Stromverbrauch.
Zählerstand.
Temperatur Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Das Heizungs-Dashboard.
Im Garten habe ich eine Steckdose im Stall.
Die kann ich schalten.
Dann habe ich die Teichtemperatur drin.
Dass ich weiß wann ich das Ganze zudecken muss im Winter.
Dass es nicht gefriert.
Und dann habe ich noch die Kameras drinne.
Das war jetzt so schnell.
Schnell Übersicht das Ganze.
Da könnte man noch viel mehr bauen.
Ich bin ein richtiger Noob im Programmieren und Co.
Ich studiere Mathe-Lehramt und muss gerade...
Verstehst du?
Du wirst dich sicherlich gut mit dem Sebaro verstehen.
Studiert der Sebaro nicht auch?
Nein, der Sebaro studiert nicht.
Was studiert denn der Cute-Mod?
Es ist nicht Mathe-Lehramt.
Aber irgendwas in der Richtung.
Biologie-Lehramt.
Ich weiß nicht was der Sebaro studiert.
Und muss gerade den Julia-Sachen-Programm...
Das kenne ich, habe ich aber noch nie was mitgemacht.
Das stimmt.
Das ist relativ angesagt zur Zeit.
Aber neuesten Stern am Programmier-Himmel würde ich jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen.
Das ist eine Sprache, die
einen gewissen Bekanntheitsgrad erreicht hat.
Und so eine relativ kleine, aber
dedicated Follower-Leute aufgebaut hat.
Und so eine relativ kleine, aber dedicated Follower-Leute aufgebaut hat.
Die das wahnsinnig hypen und geil finden.
Das ist auch gerade
im Science-Bereich glaube ich relativ beliebt.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das so die...
Das riesen Ding ist.
Also wenn du das mal vergleichst so mit...
Was für ein Trend Ruby war mit Rails
am Anfang. Da ist Julia natürlich nichts dagegen.
Oder Node.js oder Python oder sonst was.
Aber es ist schon relativ beliebt
in letzten Jahren geworden.
Ja, das kann man schon sagen.
Der Qtbot studiert Informatik.
Das kann auch sein.
Hast du eine Empfehlung für einen guten
WLAN-Router?
Nein, kauf dir gar keinen WLAN-Router.
Behalte deinen normalen Router und kauf dir
ordentliche WLAN-Access-Points.
Zum Beispiel...
Ich weiß nicht, haben die jetzt sogar
Wi-Fi 6 mittlerweile?
Zum Beispiel solche
Dinger hier.
Und die Dinger
sehen nicht umsonst so aus. Ich habe auch
den Fehler gemacht. Die mountet man am besten
an der Decke oder...
an der Wand.
Ich mache das auch nicht. Beziehungsweise noch nicht.
Aber obwohl ich die schon 2 oder 3 Jahre habe.
Weil ich zu faul war die an die
Wand zu schrauben bisher.
An die Decke kann ich bei mir nicht schrauben. Die Decke
ist nur ziemlich dünn.
Ich habe quasi Decke, Zwischendecke
und da liegen die Kabel drin
und dann die eigentliche Decke. Also ich kann den...
Also ich könnte den Access-Point unter die Platten
an der Decke machen, aber da habe ich keinen Bock mich auf die Leiter zu stellen.
Dann mache ich die Decke kaputt oder so.
Also ich werde die wahrscheinlich demnächst auch mal an die Wand schrauben.
Weil ich habe es gemerkt, jetzt gerade wo ich den
Wattchamp im Keller in Betrieb genommen habe.
Ihr erinnert euch
ja noch an den Wattchamp, das Ding was meine
Strom...
was mein Stromzähler auslässt.
Da habe ich gemerkt, ich muss den Access-Point
im Wohnzimmer unten tatsächlich mal ordentlich
auf den Kopf drehen, dass es im Keller genug ankommt,
dass es funktioniert.
Ja, also...
Reicht das für einen Nass? Jaja das reicht
dicke für einen Nass, das Ding ist huge für einen Nass.
So.
Machen wir noch mal kurz schnell den Chat, fertig?
Ich habe übrigens einen neuen...
Eins muss ich sagen, Corona
geht auch nicht so spurlos
an mir vorbei.
Ich habe das ursprünglich so als Witz angefangen
und mittlerweile ist das
so Running Gag bei mir geworden. Total, total
dämlich. Und zwar, ich habe mal so ein Video
auf YouTube drüber geguckt.
Egal, muss ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen.
Da haben sie gezeigt, wie sich Corona
Husten unterscheidet
von normalem Husten.
Und ich habe dann quasi gesagt, ich versuche das jetzt mal
nachzumachen, also Achtung
Virus durch Kabel.
Also ich habe in dem Video quasi gezeigt,
so normaler Husten ist halt
so
oder Raucher Husten oder sonst was.
Und Corona Husten ist quasi
exzellent in Interpretation hoffe ich mal.
So. Und
ich habe jetzt so
den Running Gag bei uns
ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich auf die bescheuerte Idee
gekommen bin. Jedes Mal, wenn ich
draußen rumlaufe
und das sage ich sogar teilweise, wenn ich
alleine draußen bin, ja. Und irgendjemand
in der Nähe hustet und der nicht
irgendwie, der einfach nur mal kurz
hustet, da sage ich dann immer so, teilweise
richtig dumm, so dass es sogar noch
teilweise die Leute hören, da sage ich immer, ey
typischer Corona Husten.
Teil bescheuert eigentlich. Die Leute glauben,
müssen glaube ich denken, ich bin
total gestürzt. Gut, stimmt ja auch.
Stimmt ja auch.
Ja.
Ich hängengeblieben
eigentlich, ich weiß.
Für mich ist alles typischer Corona
Husten mittlerweile.
Was ja schwachsinnig ist,
weil wenn man sich mal überlegt, dass
ein Inzidenzwert von 170
quasi bedeutet,
dass sich 0,
Leute, Leute, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz
sicher, ich glaube, ein Inzidenzwert
von 170 bedeutet,
es stecken sich 0,
1, 7
Prozent
von 100, also nein, 0,
1, 7 Prozent von 100.000 haben
Corona, oder?
170 Leute pro Woche von
100.000, ja gut, da kann man das
einfach mal durch 1000 teilen, wir machen jetzt
Quick Muffs, also ich meine, das müsste 0,
1, 7 sein, ja. Ja, genau.
Korrekt. Dann stimmt es doch, was ich
gesagt habe. Dann stimmt es
doch. Ja, wenn es 170
von 100.000 sind, dann sind es
0,1, 7 Prozent.
Das heißt, die Chance, dass
wirklich jemand ist mit
Corona Husten, den ich da draußen höre, ist doch
recht gering.
0,1, 7 Prozent am Tag stecken so
rum. Von denen
weiß man, dass sie sich angesteckt haben.
Genau, genau.
Ja.
So ist es.
Exquisite.
So, ich wollte jetzt noch eine Sache im Chat gerade.
Ja, genau,
mache ich wahrscheinlich auch, ja.
So, ich wollte jetzt noch irgendwas aus dem Chat kurz
beantworten.
Doch, doch,
ich habe ein Auto.
Ihr wisst doch, dass ich das absolute
Banger-Mobil habe
da.
Grüne Opel Agila von
2001.
Ja, habe ich gehört, habe ich gehört.
Warte mal. Irgendwas
wollte ich doch gerade
noch beantworten.
Im Chat.
Irgendwo
ging es doch hier im Access Points, Leute.
Ich wollte noch was zu Access Points sagen.
Oder irgendwas. Irgendwas hat einer von
DLAN oder so geschrieben. Genau.
Also, genau.
Also, was würdest du machen, wenn dein
Büro eine Etage über dein WLAN-Router ist?
DLAN nicht funktioniert, man kann keinen
LAN-Kabel verlegen kann. Also, das
erste ist, WLAN ist gar nicht mal
so schlecht wie sein Ruf, muss man sagen.
Also, wenn das gut ausgerichtet ist und sowas,
ist das schon in Ordnung.
Ich meine, ich würde da drüber jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Competitive Online-Spiele spielen, aber
wenn du da nicht spielen willst,
arbeiten willst, ist das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und WLAN durch eine
Etage, wenn das jetzt nicht gerade
keine Ahnung
meterdickes
Betonstahl ist,
sollte das eigentlich funktionieren.
Dazu kommt,
dass die beste Variante meiner Meinung
nach ist, nicht
dein Rechner direkt ins WLAN zu packen,
sondern so eine WLAN-Brücke
zu machen. Also sprich, du stellst
unten den Access Point im kleinen Modus in
mit einem Switch oder umgedreht
oder umgedreht oben halt, ne?
Also sprich, du überbrückst dann wirklich bloß die
Etagen damit und die Rechner schließt du weiterhin
per Netzwerk-Kabel an.
Find ich persönlich angenehmer,
zumal ich auch den Eindruck
habe, dass das Fehler,
das kann ich jetzt aber nicht bestätigen, weil ich das nicht lange
genug getestet hab, dass das problemloser
funktioniert, als wenn der Rechner direkt ins WLAN geht.
Also sprich,
du stellst oben den WLAN-Access-Point
hin, du stellst unten
den WLAN-Access-Point in, verbindest die
ganze, machst den einen kleinen Modus, verbindest das
miteinander und dann stöpselst du einen Switch an den
WLAN-Access-Point, an den Switch kommt dein Rechner.
Also sprich, dein Rechner weiß gar nichts vom
WLAN.
Das ist die bessere Variante.
Was du auch machen kannst,
was oftmals vergessen wird,
es gibt Gebäude, gerade wenn du schreibst,
dass die Stehla nicht funktioniert und man kann kein
LAN-Kabel legen, dann ist die Chance
denke ich mal
relativ gut, dass da vielleicht noch
alte Telefonleitungen liegen.
Und wenn du alte Telefonleitungen liegen hast,
kannst du die verwenden, um entweder,
vielleicht hast du Glück und es reicht
für, sagen wir mal, zumindest 100 MBit-Netzwerk.
Dann brauchst du aber
mindestens 4.
Oder zwei Stück, zwei Stück gehen
auch. Wenn du zwei Stück hast,
kannst du VDSL intern drüber machen.
Da gibt es fertige Lösungen, die machen also
unter der Haube VDSL.
Das kostet dann irgendwie so 2-300
Euro, da musst du dann oben und unten
quasi den Modem anschließen.
Die machen dann wie die Telekom VDSL, nur
im Haus über ein paar Meter. Und da funktioniert
das auch ziemlich gut.
Wenn da gar nichts liegt,
dann hast du natürlich Pech.
Wo nichts ist, kannst du da
auch noch nichts draus machen.
Was doch die nächste Variante ist, was man eventuell ausprobieren kann,
dass man eventuell Glück hat,
dass man irgendwo was ganz
dünnes noch durchbekommt, durch eben schon
bestehende Sachen, also zum Beispiel
durch Kabelschächte
irgendwie für Steckdosen oder sowas.
Wenn man Glück hat,
kann man machen. Ansonsten
bleibt dir ja gar nichts anderes
übrig, außer das zu machen,
wie ich es dir vorgeschlagen habe.
WLAN Access Point
und unten einen zweiten
WLAN Access Point im Client-Modus.
Das ist die beste Variante.
Das sieht dann ja sinngemäß so aus.
Wir machen jetzt Big Brain Paint Skills.
Du nimmst hier deinen Access Point.
Hier dein Access Point.
Was zum Teufel geht
eigentlich mit der Musik gerade ab?
Ja, genau.
Big Brain
Paint Skills.
Das ist ein Access Point. Das hier ist auch
ein Access Point, aber Client Mode
kann man ja machen.
Geht ja. Kannst du einstellen
bei jedem halbwegs gescheinen Access Point.
So, da schließt du dann
den Switch dran an.
Und an dem Switch schließt du
dann deine ganzen...
What the fuck Paint, Alter.
Und an dem Switch schließt du dann deine ganzen
Rechner an.
Und hier
dazwischen ist dann
WLAN.
Und das hier oben ist dann eigentlich
der Access Point. Du kannst das
theoretisch auch umdrehen, aber da bringt es dir nichts.
Du musst halt gucken, wo ist dein Uplink?
Wo ist dein Uplink? Wo kommst du dann
zum restlichen Netzwerk? Und da machst du den
Access Point dran.
Und hier ist dann quasi, sagen wir mal, deine Fritzbox.
So. So kann man das
machen. Huge
Presentation. Ja, ich weiß.
So, ich glaube, das hat man jetzt verstanden.
So kann man das machen.
Und das finde ich, ist besser
als diesen Rechner direkt.
Fritzbox...
Fritz Repeater ist nicht so toll, nein.
Repeater sind immer nicht so toll.
Zumal du dann nach wie vor
dein Rechner eben direkt ins WLAN
hängen willst. Und ich finde, es funktioniert einfach
besser.
Wozu der Switch? Kannst ja auch einen Router
im kleinen Mod nehmen. Also.
Das, was du als
Router bezeichnest,
ist kein Router, sondern ein Multifunktionsgerät,
wo ein Switch eingebaut ist.
Also das, was du als Router
bezeichnest, ist ein Access Point mit eingebautem
Switch. So.
Der auch routen kann. Aber
das ist genau so, wie ich das gemalt habe.
Also eine Fritzbox
mit einem Access Point ist ja genau das.
Eine Fritzbox hat einen Access Point
und hat einen Switch drinne und
kann routen zwischen verschiedenen
Interfaces. Also in der Regel wahrscheinlich
nur zwischen aus und innen, weiß ich nicht genau.
Aber das ist ja im Prinzip genau das, was ich hier
aufgemalt habe.
Der Repeater hat einen LAN-Anschluss.
Dann ist das das gleiche,
wie ich hier gemalt habe. Dann ist es kein Repeater,
sondern ein Access Point im kleinen Modus.
Deswegen einen LAN-Anschluss hat das
dann auch funktioniert. Weil du kannst
ja
nicht einen einfachen Repeater hinstellen
und einen LAN-Anschluss dran machen, dann rechnet
er gar keine Ahnung, wie er sich über LAN im WLAN anmelden soll.
Also würde mich zumindest wundern,
wenn Windows, kann Windows
WPA-Authentifizierung
über
Netzwerkkabel?
Das würde mich jetzt sehr wundern, wenn solche
Potenzial, theoretisch möglich ist das,
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Ich glaube nicht, dass
das Windows überhaupt
ein Setting hat, WPA-Authentifizierung
über Netzwerkkabel zu machen.
Das Ding heißt
wirklich Fritz Repeater. Ja, das kann ja sein,
dass es ein Repeater ist.
Aber das wird dann wahrscheinlich
also wenn du
einstellen musst an diesem Repeater,
Benutzerdaten eingehen musst
von einem WLAN, dann ist das
höchstwahrscheinlich ein Access Point im kleinen
Modus.
So.
Aber nicht desto trotz, das hier ist
auf jeden Fall die schönere Variante.
Zumal ich auch mal davon ausgehe, dass wirklich,
wenn du dir beispielsweise hier einen Unify Access Point
kaufst, hier einen Unify Access Point,
musst du mal gucken, ob die kleinen Modus können, aber relativ
sicher.
Dann ist das wahrscheinlich
besser als der Fritzbox Repeater.
Aber ich meine, wenn du den Fritzbox Repeater
kaufen willst, kannst du auch machen.
Ich kann dir nur sagen, was ich für
am besten halt.
Wenn du das dann anders machen willst, kannst du ja machen.
Du hast schon einen Unify Access Point. Ja, wie gesagt,
also die beste Variante wäre tatsächlich
die Sachen so zu verbinden, dass du hier einen
Access Point im kleinen Modus machst. Wenn du so
den Fritzbox Repeater probieren willst, kannst du auch machen.
Aber das ist meiner Ansicht nach
die beste Variante, wenn du keine
Möglichkeiten hast und auch keine alten Telefonleitungen
hast oder wenn du einfach keine Möglichkeit hast
und WLAN benutzen musst, würde, also so
würde ich das machen, hätte ich
nicht die Möglichkeit, ein Kabel irgendwie zu legen.
Huge Presentation.
Sag mal, kennst du dich mit...
Ja, haben wir doch im Stream schon öfters, haben wir öfters
was mit ESPs gemacht.
Eine batteriebetriebene Lichterkette zu steuern,
das kannst du machen, ja. Nur der
ESP-Batteriebetrieb ist schwierig, weil die
halten nicht lang. ESPs
batteriebetrieben halten nur eine Weile, wenn sie
Deep Sleepen und dann aber auch nur bestimmte ESPs,
weil die meisten normalen Developer
Boards einfach auch Deep Sleep zu viel
Strom verbrauchen.
Was ist hier eigentlich im Chat gerade schon
wieder los?
Äh, ungefähr 8 Watt
Eidl, wenn du Stromsparfunktion einschaltest.
Also gar nicht mal so viel mehr, als
ein Raspberry Pi unter Volllast. Wobei
ein Raspberry Pi 4 unter Volllast geht, glaube ich,
bis auf 14-15 Watt.
Genauso, du musst mal im Stream Archive gucken,
da haben wir das irgendwo schon gemacht.
Im Prinzip ist es eigentlich relativ einfach.
Du brauchst
ne Domain,
es reicht auch ne DuckDNS-Domain.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall ne Domain, die extern
verflüssbar ist. So.
Das ist das Wichtige.
Und, ähm, dann nimmst du irgendeinen
kleinen Programm, was das kann, zum
Beispiel Certbot. Wobei Certbot
ein bisschen hakelig ist. Du nimmst halt
irgendeinen Let's Encrypt-Kleinprogramm,
was DNS-Authentifizierung kann.
Dort hinterlegst du die Zugangsdaten zu deinem
DNS-Anbieter. Also es muss
ein DNS-Anbieter sein, der API-Zugriff
unterstützt. Ansonsten musst du das von Hand
machen und das ist dann auf Dauer nicht schön, gerade
beim Verlängern. Geht auch, würde ich aber
nicht empfehlen. Und dann macht der das
eigentlich automatisch für dich. Also mal angenommen,
du bist bei Cloudflare.
Mal angenommen, du bist bei Cloudflare. Dann nimmst du irgendein
x-beliebiges, muss man auf GitHub ein bisschen gucken.
Wie gesagt, Certbot kann's auch, aber ich glaube, in
Certbot ist es ein bisschen komplizierter. Guck mal,
Certbot Cloudflare
DNS-Challenge.
Och wobei, guck mal, so schwer ist es
doch gar nicht. Also mal angenommen,
dein DNS ist bei Cloudflare.
Dann würdest du
so mit einem
Certbot
ein Zertifikat über
DNS-Challenge dir holen.
Hier musst du deine Cloudflare-Credentials
reinschreiben. Kannste ja generieren bei Cloudflare.
Und dann führst du das aus und dann kriegst du
dein Zertifikat. Wichtig ist,
du brauchst ein Domain und einen DNS-Server,
den du über eine API steuern kannst.
Weil das funktioniert ja folgendermaßen.
Let's Encrypt
muss ja sicherstellen, dass du der
rechtmäßige Besitzer dieser Domain bist.
Und die lösen einfach die Domain
auf und fragen
den Text-Record ab. Und in diesem Text-Record
muss ein geheimer Schlüssel hinterlegt
sein, den nur du
kennst.
So, beziehungsweise, was heißt
den nur du kennst, das stimmt nicht.
Den nur du dort hinterlegen kannst. Also
Let's Encrypt erwartet, dass da ein bestimmter Schlüssel
steht und nur du, weil du der
rechtmäßige Besitzer der Domain bist und Zugriff auf
den DNS hast, kannst diesen Schlüssel dort
hinterlegen. Das heißt,
dann ruft Let's Encrypt ein TXT-Record
ab von deinem DNS und
guckt, ob da das Richtige drinsteht. Wenn das Richtige drinsteht,
kriegst du ein Zertifikat.
So funktioniert das.
So.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir alles durch.
Monkathos, ja.
Ja, das ist auch nice. Das habe ich
noch nie ausprobiert. Also es gibt da sicherlich
noch die ein oder anderen Tricks,
wie man das noch besser hinbekommen kann.
Aber wie gesagt, das erste, was mir einfallen würde,
ist so, so würde ich das auch machen.
Ja, wenn es natürlich noch bessere Varianten gibt,
dann schadet es ja nicht, hier auszuprobieren.
Oh, was hast du geschrieben?
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Was?
Du hast überhaupt nichts geschrieben.
Was für ein Auto.
Es kann auch sein, dass das funktioniert.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns
mal, was gucken wir uns denn
auf YouTube heute an? Wir gucken uns definitiv
keine Corona-News an, soviel kann ich euch sagen.
Was ist denn
stabiler, D-Lan oder AP im
Client-Modus? AP im Client-Modus ist
absolut unproblematisch, wenn der Empfang
gut ist, genauso wie bei D-Lan, was auch
recht unproblematisch ist, wenn
das Stromnetz okay ist
und nicht Leute
random die Mikrowelle anschalten dazwischen.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich, wenn ich
die Möglichkeit hätte, guten Empfang hätte,
ich würde wahrscheinlich Client-Modus,
ich würde ein Access Point nehmen im Client-Modus.
Oder das irgendwie anders
übers W-Lan bridgeen.
Also so Sachen wie
D-Lan und Geschiss würde ich echt nur
auspacken, wenn ich W-Lan
technisch das überhaupt nicht mehr anders
machen könnte.
Das ist gut gemacht, die Sounds,
Lul.
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an?
Genau, wir lassen uns
jebaiten, wir lassen uns wieder eine Runde von Level Cap
jebaiten.
Habt ihr eigentlich
alle schon mein aktuelles Video geguckt?
Ich hab nämlich schon gestern ein Video hochgeladen,
wo ich erzähle, wo ich
bei meinem ersten Arbeitgeber, wo man
das Fenster
von einem
Rechenzentrum von
einer Wohnung geschrottet haben, ihr habt ja geguckt.
Exquisite.
Auch Views gehen doch durchaus in Ordnung,
dass das jetzt ein Thema ist, was vielleicht nicht
komplett jeden interessiert.
Du benutzt gerade meinen Hetzner
Code. Exquisite, so muss das
sein. Sponsor Block Whitelisted.
Ja, das machen ja wirklich nur absolute
Sixheads. Also Leute,
wenn ihr besonderen IQ Boost wollt, Sponsor
Block für mich rausnehmen.
Hetzner Code eingelöst.
Ja, so mag ich das, so mag ich das.
Leute, ich hab
mal eine Frage an euch. Ich weiß,
die meisten von euch haben da wahrscheinlich auch keine Ahnung
von, aber ich frage euch mal. Meint ihr, es ist
sinnvoll, oder
was für eine Kategorie, oder umgedreht,
was für eine Kategorie
ist für so ein Video
sinnvoller? Gaming
oder Science and Technology?
Science and Technology.
Es ist ja beides irgendwie.
Gaming bringt mehr Klicks, bin
ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das so ist.
Ja, es gibt kein
Laberstellz.
Also ihr meint Science and Technology.
Da stelle ich das noch um.
Gaming mehr Money?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist gar nicht so offensichtlich.
Ah, das ist gar nicht so offensichtlich.
Gaming hat wahrscheinlich
insgesamt mehr Views, aber das sagt ja
überhaupt nichts für
ein Video bei mir aus.
Ich probiere das, glaube ich, mal mit Science and Technology.
Wo habe ich denn das alte eingestellt?
Wartet mal, wo habe ich denn das letzte eingestellt?
Ich habe doch letztens ein Video gemacht,
hier.
Filmwer update geht schief, schlüpfen
Wartungsarbeiten meines Lebens, wo habe ich denn das
sieht man das nicht?
Filmwer update geht schief, schlüpfen Wartungsarbeiten
meines Lebens, wo habe ich denn das?
Sieht man das irgendwo?
Sieht man irgendwo
in welcher Kategorie ein Video eingestellt
wurde?
Kann man das vielleicht
im, da steht Gaming?
Echt, wo, wo? Ach, hier.
Ha.
Okay,
ist bei allen Gaming, ist das Gaming?
So,
ich nehme jetzt mal was, wo ich definitiv
weiß, dass ich Science and Technology
eingestellt habe.
Ha, guck mal, hier steht das nicht.
So, und hier ist,
und hier ist, und hier ist auch Gaming
eingestellt, alles Gaming.
Ah.
Okay.
Show more,
ne, auf Show more steht da nichts.
Show more
steht da nichts, ne, ne.
Okay, okay, okay. Also,
sprich, das letzte,
das hat er echt gesagt, Azubi
verkackts richtig, das ist Gaming.
Das haben viele geguckt. Irgendwie
erkenne ich den als kein großes, und unglaubliche
Geschichte meiner Abschlussprüfung, ist auch Gaming.
Also, hier habe ich auch Science and
Technology eingestellt.
Und da sieht man auch nicht, dass,
aber da steht kein Gaming. Okay, okay,
verstehe.
Okay.
Übrigens, die haben
geantwortet, ne. Ich hätte, ich
habe das voll falsch verstanden, ihre Stellenanzeige
in dem Video.
Komplett, komplett falsch, ja.
Natürlich.
Was sonst?
Dann haben sie es so getan, als hätte ich absichtlich falsch
verstanden.
Na gut, vielleicht probiere ich das
mal aus und stelle das auf Science and Technology.
Kann man ja alles nachträglich noch
umstellen. So, lassen
wir uns mal von Level Cap debaten, schnell.
Ja, ja, so haben sie es hingestellt, ne.
Okay,
lassen wir uns mal debaten von Level Cap.
Kannst du mir sagen,
Moment. Kannst du
mir sagen, ob man mit einem Realton Abschluss
mit 2,8er Durchschnitt einschalten muss? Klar,
natürlich.
Kriegst du ohne
Probleme.
Ich meine, vielleicht klappt es
nicht beim ersten, aber das muss auch mit
einem 1er Durchschnitt nicht beim ersten klappen.
Aber das
ist jetzt nichts, was dich
daran hindern sollte, was zu bekommen.
Ach.
Die meisten Firmen haben Dachschaden. Ist überhaupt
kein Problem, kriegst du.
Kriegst du.
Also, es sollte dich nicht davon abhalten, nicht dazu
bewerben.
Ich meine, die meisten Firmen wollen auch jemand
in ihrer Stellenanzeige, der
Vmware kann, Hyper-V kann, Linux kann,
Windows kann, AD kann, Cloud kann,
Kubernetes kann, Docker kann, Telefonsupport
kann, äh, Kaffee
kann, Boden putzen kann,
Azubis ausbilden kann, Banking-Systeme
kann, Host, Großrechner kann,
Cobol kann, ABAP kann, C, C++
kann, C-Sharp kann, Go
kann, Terraform kann, Ansible
kann, alles mögliche kann, was ja auch
Schwachsinn ist. Also, die haben die
das, was sie schreiben und die Realität gehen
immer ein bisschen auseinander.
Der auch noch Projektmanagement
kann genau, äh,
das ist, das ist
eh die geilste Taktik immer, ne?
Weil ich das manchmal in Stellenan-
Stellenbeschreibungen seh. Die suchen auf der einen
Seite wirklich, äh, Big-Brain-Techniker-
Leute und dann noch irgendjemand,
der, äh, zusätzlich noch Teamleiter
und Projektmanager ist. Sowas gibt es
in einer Person nicht.
Ok, sag niemals nie, vielleicht gibt's von 100.000
ein, also es gibt auf jeden Fall
weniger davon als Corona- äh, Patienten,
ja.
Bei Corona gibt's ja relativ viel mittlerweile.
Und Rechenzentrum in der Wohnung bauen muss man auch
können, ja. Oder zumindest,
zumindest, äh,
sollte man das insoweit können, dass man,
dass einem kein Server auf den Fuß fällt.
Ich hab euch schon mal erzählt, dass bei dem,
was, bei, also jetzt nicht bei der Sache
in der Wohnung, sondern bei einer anderen,
äh, Server-Schlepp-Aktion,
dass mal einer, einem einen Vollbelaner
2 HE-Server auf den Fuß gefallen ist, ne?
Hab ich euch das mal erzählt, richtiger
Paint-Champ, der hatte keine Sicherheitsschuhe
oder sonst was an.
Und wenn ihr sonst, das war ein DL,
HP, ne, ne, HP
DL 3
ein alter, die
noch so rot und silber waren.
Nein, nein, nicht die, die auch nicht, die ganz
alten, sowas hier eher in die Richtung,
sowas hier war das.
So ein Ding ist dem Vollbelaner auf den Fuß gefallen.
Der war dann 2 Wochen weg.
Ne, Fuß war nicht ab, aber
C war, glaube ich, durchgebrochen
komplett.
Und war dann 2 Wochen weg.
Deswegen,
so, so, gewisserweise sind so
Arbeitsschutzmaßnahmen
und, und, äh,
gewisse Vorschriften, die manche haben,
nicht verkehrt.
2 HE-USV auf dem Fuß,
ok, das ist noch schwerer als das Ding.
Deswegen, es ist gar nicht so schlecht, sich
anzuzielen und sowas.
Kann jemand die
Auszählung klippen? Ja, kannst du immer noch machen.
Kein Problem, im Zweifelsfall gehst du ins Watt.
Oder, äh,
klickst du jetzt auf klipp und scrollst zurück.
Aber könnte, könnte, könnte schon mal einer klippen.
Das passt
eigentlich ganz gut. Kann ich
dann immer, wenn irgendjemand fragt, so, was soll ich können,
kann ich das dann abspielen.
Das mach ich dann ins Meme-Board rein, wenn das einer
klippt. Und wenn jemand fragt, so,
hier, was muss ich in meiner Ausbildung können, dann, dann
sag ich das, dann spiel ich das von
eben ab. Hattest du mal was mit Abab
zu tun? Nee, zum Glück nicht. Wie gesagt,
so ein Ding ist einem auf den Fuß gefallen, das hat halt echt
Rums gemacht.
Richtiger Pains-Champ.
So, also, aber 2 HE-USV
ist auch Pains-Champ, das ist noch schwerer.
Wisst ihr, wie viele Bewerbungen ich geschrieben habe
für meine Ausbildungsstelle?
Die Leute, die eine Weile, die eine Weile
dabei sind, die wissen es wahrscheinlich.
Eine ist falsch.
Zwei.
Ach nee, du hast zwei geschrieben.
Ich hab zwei geschrieben. Ja, es stimmt aber
auch, ich hab auch zwei geschrieben.
Ich hab zwei geschrieben.
Und zwar,
die erste, an
irgend so einen
Programmier-Stells-Laden
hier in der Nähe.
Und die hatten in ihrer, die hatten
auf ihrer Webseite stehen, damals schon.
Ich mein, überlegt euch mal, das ist 2005
oder so war das.
Nee, 2006.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Das ist lange her. Und
die hatten da was stehen von sie machen
.NET und Paisen-Zeugs.
Und das Ganze schon 2005 oder 2006
rum. Und
da hab ich mich beworben bei denen damals.
Und ich hab ihnen sogar Beispiel-Code mitgeschickt.
Ich hab damals, damals, also
ich hab damals ein Plugin gebaut für
weiß ich, ich kenn noch einen Media-Portal.
Das war so ein Media-Center. Hab ich damals
ein Plugin für gebastelt in C-Sharp
und hab auch ein bisschen Paisen-Zeug,
E-Mail-Filter mitgeschickt.
Jaja, die waren richtig, richtig
massive. Das war, frag mich nicht,
welche Paisen-Version das war.
Die waren richtig, die waren richtig, richtig
modern damals schon.
Das konnte ich damals ganz gut.
Weil
ich hab ein Paisen-Buch gekauft.
Und zwar, das war so ein
graues Buch, Moment, Moment.
So ein grau,
das da.
Das ist aber nicht grau.
Aber das ist das.
Also meins, vielleicht ist die neue Ausgabe, vielleicht
ist die neue Ausgabe nicht grau.
Damals hab ich es noch mit Büchern
gelernt, ja.
Objekte, Michael Weigand,
da kann ich mir noch an den Namen erinnern,
von 2005 ist das Buch. Ich bilde mir ein,
das Buch war grau, oder
bringt mich das jetzt voll durcheinander?
Sekunde.
Warum, warum denke ich, also manchmal glaube ich
echt, mein Gehirn funktioniert nicht mal richtig jetzt
mit 36. Ich war mir sicher, das war
ein braunes, ein graues
Buch. Dann muss das graue Buch
was anderes gewesen sein.
Sekunde, ich muss mal in meine
Amazon-Shopping-Historie gucken.
Your Orders.
Was, ich soll mich neu anmelden? Amazon App,
please. Ich hab doch keine Ahnung, wie mein
Passwort ist aus dem Kopf, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Hä? Jetzt muss ich mich nicht mehr
anmelden. Ok, Amazon.
Alles klar.
Ich glaub, das war das Bash-Buch, was ich in
grau habe.
Welches Buch war das,
was ich, ich weiß, ich hatte so ein
graues Buch zu irgendeiner Programmiersprache,
was war das?
Gut, ich
höre jetzt auf zu gucken, es interessiert euch
wahrscheinlich absolut nicht die Bohne, was ich für ein Buch gekauft habe,
was grau ist, aber
Ruby on Rails 3.2 habe
ich ein Buch, null, wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich hab ernsthaft ein Buch, Ruby
on Rails 3.2,
von 2013,
da war da Ruby nicht schon wieder, war da Ruby nicht
schon wieder out,
dann habe ich von 2012
JIT,
JIT, verteilte Versionsverwaltung,
dann habe ich von 2012, Effective
C-Sharp,
Windows Presentation Foundation,
Alter, was habe ich mir
für Bücher alles mal gekauft,
es wird ja immer schlimmer, 2012
Windows Presentation Foundation, also
WPF,
WPF 2009,
Alter,
reguläre Ausdrücke,
kurz und gut, von 2008,
Z
und AWK, kurz und gut,
2008,
wird ja immer schlimmer,
ja,
Regex, kurz und gut,
wenn ich mal so richtig schreiben könnte,
oh, was ist das, alles klar,
kurz und gut, das waren diese O'Reilly-Bücher,
okay,
ich darf nicht nach Regex, ich muss nach
reguläre Ausdrücke suchen,
das sah genau, das mit
der Eule, das mit der Eule habe ich,
und dann habe ich auch Z und AWK,
kurz und gut, lull,
Leute, ich bin mega verwirrt, ich weiß genau,
ich habe ein Buch, das ist komplett grau,
und, war das
vielleicht das Shellscript im Buch?
Ich habe ja noch so ein Shellscript
im Buch mal gekauft,
da war das nicht Bash,
da war das Shell,
ja, Shellscript
in Programmierung 2008,
genau,
das habe ich 2008
gekauft, das da,
ja, genau, das meinte ich,
fragt mich nicht, wie ich jetzt
auf so, ihr muss jetzt leider, bei mir
in einer recht langweiligen Sache zu gucken,
wie ich mir alte Programmierbücher aus meiner Amazon-Historie
raussuche, aber 2008, also
da könnt ihr euch mal überlegen, wie lange ich den ganzen
Müll schon mache,
das ist OnlyBigBrain,
wie bin ich da jetzt überhaupt drauf gekommen,
ja, was weiß ich denn,
das ist Amazon-Historie beste,
wie bin ich denn jetzt da drauf gekommen, was wollte ich denn
damit erzählen, achso, genau,
weil ich dem, ähm,
Peißenzeug,
weil ich, weil ich Peißenzeug
damals, genau, also ich, genau, ich habe,
jetzt weiß ich wieder, wie ich das, also ich habe zwei,
zeig mal her,
ich meine, die meisten Firmen
wollen in ihrer Stellenanzeige,
der Vmware kann, Hyper-V kann,
Linux kann, Windows kann, AD kann,
Cloud kann, Kubernetes kann,
Docker kann, Telefonsupport kann,
Kaffeekochen kann,
Bodenputzen kann, Azubis ausbilden
kann, Banking-Systeme kann,
Host, Großrechner kann, Cobalt kann,
ABAP kann, C, C++ kann,
C-Sharp kann, Go kann,
Terraform kann, Ansible kann,
alles mögliche kann, was ja auch Schwachsinn ist,
das, was sie schreiben
und die Realität gehen immer ein bisschen auseinander.
Ja, nice,
nice geklippt, exquisite.
Ruby.
Genau, und ich hab's, wie gesagt, ich hab zwei
Bewerbungen geschrieben, und auf
den ersten bin ich heute noch, bin ich heute
noch sauer, ich hab mir da voll Mühe
gegeben, ne?
Ich hab mit denen telefoniert, weil ich gesagt hab hier
eine Zeige gesehen, und
ich hatte ja auch nicht den allerbesten Abschluss,
deswegen hatte ich damals angerufen, bin dann auch
beim Chef rausgekommen, das war ein relativ kleiner Laden,
ich hab gesagt, ich schick ihm eine Bewerbung,
paar Codebeispiele, und ich hab mir
übelst Mühe gegeben, ne? Ich hab meinen alten
Python Übungscode noch mal rausgekramt,
da hab ich, da hab ich für mich
gebastelt, irgendwie, dass er E-Mails automatisch
anhand einem gewissen Absender wegfiltert
und so, also, also eigentlich
schon viel mehr, als man jetzt vielleicht mal von einem Azubi
am Anfang erwarten würde, und hab das voll
aufgemotzt, das Programm, also
so, dass es funktioniert noch richtig,
ich hab Kommentare überall hingeschrieben,
ich hab da bestimmt 4-5 Stunden dran rumgemacht,
dass es wirklich 1A aussieht,
wie gesagt, für eine Bewerbung, ne?
Und, äh,
die haben nie geantwortet.
Die haben weder
abgesagt, noch sonst was,
die haben einfach nie geantwortet, und das finde ich
ist immer eine Sauerei, also ich finde,
wenn man sich, wenn es jemand
für, äh,
also, die jeweilige Firma für
gut genug erachte,
sich dazu bewerben,
dann sollte man auch, zumindest
absagen. Man muss ja noch nicht
immer großartig was schreiben, einfach
nur sagen, ja, äh,
was, was, ich viel, viel Glück auf ihrem
weiteren Weg, oder, oder so,
so, irgendwie Standardfloskel, kurz eine Mücke
an der Wand machen, so,
exzellent, ähm, irgendwie Standardfloskel
rein, meinetwegen, aber einfach nichts
schreiben, es suckt.
Und das, obwohl ich mir da wirklich
richtig Mühe gegeben habe, den Beispielcode
ordentlich zu machen, ich weiß immer, ich frag mich
ernsthaft, warum die mich nicht genommen haben, so doof,
also, ich, wie gesagt, ich will
nicht hier, äh,
Max-Angeb-FPS machen, ne, aber
ich weiß echt nicht, warum sie sich nicht gemeldet haben,
weil ich glaube nicht, dass
es, äh, viele andere Azubis
gab, die damals,
äh, gut, würde ich wahrscheinlich
heute noch so einen halbwegs gut geschriebenen
Python-Code komplett kommentiert, funktionsfähig,
und, äh, auch, auch,
auch von der Logik her nicht so easy
hatten und ein funktionierendes
Media-Portal C-Sharp-Plugin.
Ich glaube, da hast du damals nicht allzu viele
Azubis gefunden in dem Bereich, die das hätten
machen können.
Also, keine Ahnung, warum die sich nicht gemeldet haben.
Welche Steckdose kannst du empfehlen?
Irgendeine, die du mit Tasmota flashen kannst, und das ist
immer, äh, tagesaktuell.
Ja, ja, das war altes Python.
Was war denn das jetzt nochmal für eine Version?
Hier, zack.
Für Python-Version?
Ja, ja.
Welche, welche Python-Version
wird hier besprochen? War das schon zwei?
Weiß man jetzt nicht so genau.
Python-Version-Historie.
Aber ich glaube, das war zwei, und zwei war
relativ neu.
Ja, ja, genau, genau.
Ja, ja, es war, genau, es war
zwei, ich glaube, es war
zwei, zwei, vier, nee,
zu vier gab's nicht.
Zwei, zwei, oder zwei, fünf?
Nee, das war dann wahrscheinlich zwei, zwei.
Genau.
Naja, gut, wir dem auch zwei.
Lange genug geschwätzt, jetzt gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an.
Äh, die wenigsten kriegen
mehr als Hello World hin, ja, noch nicht mal das.
Die meisten kriegen...
Aber gut, ich meine, das ist ja auch nicht nur ein Zweck eines Azubis,
das schon zu können, das sage ich immer.
Aber ich hätte ganz ehrlich, wenn ich, wenn ich,
äh, wenn ich
Azubi aussuchen würde,
dann würde ich auch lieber den nehmen,
der da schon was kann.
Klar, es ist natürlich wichtiger,
muss man, muss man auch mal klar sagen,
dass ich, dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich komme
mit der Person gut klar und die
eignet sich gut für meine Firma.
Aber, ähm, wenn ich die Auswahl habe,
dann zwischen einem, der Kearnung hat, und einem,
der schon ein bisschen programmieren kann,
dann weiß ich auch, okay, der ist schon mal ganz gut aufgehoben.
Ja.
Wegen Abi zu jung abgelehnt hat, am Ende habe ich mich
erzählt, dass...
Ja.
Manchmal, manchmal funktioniert es
unbeabsichtigt am besten,
ja.
WPF war damals der
neueste Shit, leider,
hat das Microsoft
ja bis heute nicht geschafft, was rauszubringen,
was, äh, WPF
ablöst. WPF war nie so, nie so
richtig gut fertig,
und Microsoft hat irgendwann gesagt, machen
wir nichts mal dran, dann kam Microsoft auf
die Idee, wir machen UWP, UWP ist bis
heute auch nicht fertig und hat immer noch Probleme
und suckt eigentlich, gerade,
dass man Codesigning-Zertifikate und so einen Schrott
braucht, was, was Microsoft
sich dabei gedacht hat. Jetzt haben sie WinUI
am Start, WinUI sollte angeblich,
äh, jetzt das erste
richtig gute UI-Framework für Windows
wieder werden, was für alles funktioniert, und was
haben sie gesagt? Nein. Unpackaged App,
ähm, machen wir
nicht. Also auch schon wieder
Fail. Microsoft verscheißt
ihre vernachlässigen
GUI-Sachen auf Windows gnadenlos.
Kein Wunder, dass die Leute nur noch Elektron-Anwendungen machen.
Ihr bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig.
In Zukunft vielleicht Flutter, vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Boot, aber was anderes gibt es ja aktuell nicht.
Basti, ne, Bzati,
Dankeschön für Twitch Prime Subscription.
Die haben sich einfach den E-Mail-Code gekauft, ja.
Ihr habt ihr Codes mitgeschickt
für eurer Bewerbung. Ich habe mich
damals bei denen per E-Mail beworben und habe ihnen
zwei Code Pro mitgeschickt. Einmal
das Python-E-Mail-Filter-Ding und einmal
mein Media-Portal
C-Sharp-Plugin.
Wohlgemerkt, für eine Firma, die Python und C-Sharp
macht, und das als Azubi, also, nein,
was willst du eigentlich mehr haben?
Ich guck
gleich in die Abos rein.
Ja, es ist
teilweise echt unglaublich. Ich dachte ja
früher, also ich muss sagen,
ich hab eigentlich die Leute
früher viel besser eingeschätzt,
als sie letztendlich sind, oder
wie drücke ich denn das jetzt aus?
Also ich dachte, ich dachte früher,
als ich, sagen wir mal, so
20 war,
dachte ich immer, okay, die Generation,
die jetzt nach mir kommt, für die
wird vieles von dem, was ich jetzt
hier mache und so, selbstverständlich
sein, das kann dann jeder.
Also ich bin davon ausgegangen, jeder kann dann später mal einen Rechner
mit ihm, jeder kann einen Internetanschluss einrichten,
jeder kann irgendwie so die Basic-Technik-Sachen
machen. Das Witzige ist, woran ich nicht gedacht
hab, ist, dass die Leute
genauso wenig können, wie früher.
Früher konnten die Leute nichts,
weil das was Neues war
oder sich nicht damit beschäftigen wollten.
Und heute können die Leute nichts, weil
es zu selbstverständlich ist, dass es
da ist. Ja, heute ist ein
Internetanschluss, okay, in Deutschland jetzt mal außen vor,
heute ist ein Internetanschluss einfach da
und der funktioniert in der Regel und kann auch jeder
Voll-Dab einrichten. Die Leute sind
komplett überfordert, wenn mal irgendwas nicht geht.
Die können einfach so
Debugging-Sachen nicht machen.
Und das ist das, wo ich den Leuten
früher, also voraus schon
viel mehr zugetraut habe, als sich
heute eigentlich bewahrheitet hat.
Ja, wir lassen uns jetzt gleich
von LevelCaptureBane.
Elektron ist insofern
nice, wenn du was einfaches
zusammenbasteln willst als Web-Entwickler.
Für alles andere ist Elektron nicht nice.
GitHub-Link auf Lebenslauf, ja, kann man
machen, aber 2006 war mit
Shithub-Link noch nicht so viel.
Das Wort gefällt ihr früher, ne?
Richtig, ohne Mist sehe ich genauso.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht,
ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, die Generation, die nach
uns kommt, macht die Sachen selbstverständlich.
Easy as fuck.
Aber ist nicht so.
Wie gesagt, mich hat letztens,
ja, hab ich erzählt
im Stream, mich hat letztens der
Sohn vom Nachbar angerufen,
mittags, auf dem Handy von
meiner Mutter, total um fünf Ecken,
ja, hat mich der Sohn
angerufen von meinem Nachbar und
wollte wissen, ob ich
ihm helfen kann bei der Windows-
Netzwerk-Config.
Ich fand, ich hab mit dem,
ich hab damit keine Schmerzen, ich fand's
irgendwie noch, ich fand's irgendwie auch ganz
witzig, dass er mich angerufen hat, ja.
Aber ich frag mich erstens, woher weiß er das?
Wahrscheinlich hat es ihm seinen Vater erzählt, mit dem rede ich ja ab und zu mal.
Und ich hab mit dem noch nicht
ein Wort gewechselt.
Ich hab mit dem noch nie gesprochen.
Und er ruft mich an so,
so nach dem Motto,
ja, Max, mein Rechner geht nicht.
Fand ich eigentlich ganz cool, aber
ich hab mit ihm noch nie geredet vorher.
Nein, leider nicht.
Ich installiere im nächsten Stream einfach Ubuntu
Ubuntu 10.0.2 oder
10.0.4 und da geht
Compets noch.
Du meinst mein Tesla?
Der ist so. True.
True, null W.
Okay.
Nein, ich konnte ihm da gar nicht helfen.
Ich hab ihm gesagt, was er
für IP-Settings einstellen muss an seiner
Netzwerkkarte, aber das war's.
Dann ging's nicht und dann wusste ich Remote nicht weiter.
Und ich wollte in Corona-Zeiten
nicht sagen, komm, ich komm
mal kurz rüber gucken.
Okay, also
jetzt gucken wir uns mal eine Runde Level Cap an und lassen uns
zu Bane.
Laut genug?
Ist ja immer ein bisschen
das Problem, dass Windows zwischen zwei Streams die Audio
Settings verstellt.
Ohje, ohje, Warzone Upgrades.
In der Regel, sobald ein neues Warzone Upgrade
rauskommt, ist er erstmal kaputt.
Habt ihr, hat jemand von euch
Warzone gespielt die letzten Wochen,
wo diese Pistols am Start waren?
Diese Pistols, die ultra schnell
gefeuert haben, ultra schnell gekillt haben und viel
Munition hatten, wo ich mir auch so denke.
Wie kommt sowas immer durch, ja?
Ne, ne, Level Cap,
das stimmt nicht.
Eigentlich war das Jahr überhaupt nicht
voll. Das Jahr, es gab
nur immer mal wieder irgendwelche Leute,
unter anderem Level Cap selbst,
der absolut
unsinnige, unspektakuläre
Dinge zu
Huge Leaks gemacht
hat.
Man weiß eigentlich, nennt wirklich
was.
Moment, Moment, Moment, das müssen wir mal kurz
lesen. Also
Return of All Out Warfare, da hat die Marketing
Abteilung schon wieder zugeschlagen. Ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen
Sound im Hintergrund an.
Da hat die Marketing Abteilung schon wieder zugeschlagen.
Moment, ich brauche eine andere Musik.
Halt schnell aus.
Also
2021 ist
so aufregende Zeiten für DICE, ja
ok.
Ja, World Class Developer Studios,
bla, bla, bla.
Also sie haben das größte Team
überhaupt an, das glaube ich denen
sogar. Allerdings der Witz ist,
ich hab's ja auch schon
bei anderen Produktionen gesagt,
ein größeres Entwicklerteam
ist nicht gleich ein
besseres Spiel.
Ihr guckt euch Call of Duty
oder irgendwelche Blizzard Sachen an in letzter Zeit.
Also, nur
weil du viele Leute drauf
schmeißt, bedeutet das nicht automatisch,
dass da was Gutes bei rauskommt. Also das ist jetzt ja
kein Argument für die Qualität.
So, Kriterien, das sind glaube ich die Need for Speed
Dudes. DICE LA, das waren
früher mal Danger Close.
Ist DICE LA nicht die
Medal of Honor? Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Mit den zwei Kassenschlagern schlechthin.
Ok, im Prinzip sagen sie, im Prinzip
sagen sie gar nichts.
Alter, diese Super
Lativen immer.
Jaw-Dropping
Experience. Das hätte auch von der
Apple Präsentation sein können, oder?
Bei Apple wäre das Whooping gewesen, oder?
So was, Whooping haben sie
gerne gesagt auf der letzten Apple Präsentation.
Amazing ist ja schon, ist ja schon
out.
Ok, erster Abschnitt, schon mal absolut
nichts, nichts gesagt.
Nichts, absolut nichts.
Mindblowing, nichts, Mindblowing
nichts gesagt. So, ok.
We're in daily playtesting mode.
Hallo, du playtestest dein Spiel
eigentlich von Anfang an?
Du kannst nicht einfach mal drei Jahre entwickeln
und dann sagen, ok,
ein halbes Jahr,
bevor wir es releasen,
spielen wir es zum ersten Mal selbst. Ok, kann man schon,
kommt dann sowas wie Battlefield 5 dabei raus
wahrscheinlich. Oder Anthem,
Anthem kommt dann dabei raus.
Aber ich glaube, es ist nicht
nur zweck der Sache, drei Jahre zu entwickeln
und dann ein halbes Jahr vorher anfangen selbst zu spielen.
Alles klar.
I can tell you...
Die Bolze...
Die schwätzen immer im Kreisel, Schwätzer
sind das. Der Fabian ist der Kreisel
Grinder in MMOs und die Marketing
Abteilung hier sind die Kreisel Schwätzer.
Nichts gesagt.
It has everything we love,
bla bla bla. Das gleiche
habt ihr zu Battlefield 1 auch gesagt.
Zu Battlefield 5 auch gesagt, ging dann voll
in die Hose.
Next Level...
Next... Ohne Mist
Frage an euch, die in der IT arbeiten.
Ich weiß, gibt ein paar.
Next Level muss
irgendwie auf einer Marketing
oder Führungskräfte
Rhetorikseminar müssen die das aktuell
verkaufen, weil alle unsere
Manager in übrigen Regionen
sagen seit einem Jahr
ungefähr zu allem
Next Level. Und ich
lese Next Level auch total oft jetzt
so seit eins, zwei Jahren in allen möglichen
Marketingmaterial. Ich hab den Eindruck
irgendwie so der
Management...
Management Rhetorik Guru hat
irgendwann mal gesagt Next Level ist das Wort,
was man jetzt benutzen muss
für sowas.
Und die schreien
jetzt alle Next Level.
So, Epics
Ge... Alter, dieses 0815
leere Gelaber.
Mich nervt das immer so richtig.
Ich mein, was soll uns das denn überhaupt jetzt sagen?
Es soll uns sagen,
dass die Marketing Abteilung
ihr eigenes Game gut redet.
Ach, no shit, da wären wir nicht
draufgekommen.
Epic Scale All-Out
Military Warfare, was auch immer das heißt.
Crazy Unexpected Moments
Game Changing Destruction
Massive Battles
Okay, okay, okay
der letzte
Satz ist das
einzig sinnvolle in diesem gesamten Post.
Get ready for reveal soon.
Das ist der
einzige Satz mit irgendeiner halbwegs
greifbaren Aussage, so nach dem Motto
Leute, demnächst gibt's was.
Eventuell.
Aber...
Ansonsten...
Oh, Reddit Post
Where ist das Reddit Flame Post?
Okay, wir gucken uns
die Runde Reddit Flame Post, warte mal, das muss ich mal kurz
aufmachen, das hier.
If you're going to buy Battlefield 6,
don't forget.
Ja, gut,
ich hab Battlefield 5 halt
nicht wirklich gespielt, deswegen kann ich dazu nichts sagen.
Das verstehe ich gar nicht, warum es die Leute
darüber aufregen.
Ich mein, nur
weil man sich selbst jebaiten lassen hat,
mehr zu bezahlen,
kann man sich doch jetzt nicht drüber beschweren,
dass andere weniger bezahlt haben.
Hat er sich halt jebaiten lassen, da kann er
die anderen, die weniger bezahlt haben, nichts für.
Und gerade Battlefield 5 mussten die ja im Endeffekt
Sales machen, weil
das Spiel hat sich am Anfang keiner gekauft.
Okay, bla bla bla.
Anti-Cheat
und Auto-Balance.
Ja, da sehe ich auch ein bisschen Probleme
beim neuen Battlefield, gerade was
Balancing-Sachen angeht.
Dadurch, dass es eventuell keine
oder ziemlich sicher keine
klassischen Server mehr zum Selbsthosten gibt.
Also, Selbsthosten, klassische Server
selbst gibt's ja schon lange nicht mehr, aber nicht mal mit
irgendwelchen Plugin-Schnittstellen
sacked halt.
Okay, Firestorm haben sie halt komplett in Sand gesetzt, da hat er recht.
Combat Arms, kann ich mir nicht mehr dran erinnern, ich hab das ja
auch nicht gespielt.
Das hab ich auch nicht mitbekommen,
aber das ist kacke.
Das würde ich auch nicht unterstützen wollen.
Kann ich nichts zu sagen, hab ich nicht gespielt.
Äh, keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht gespielt.
Also, ich hab's gespielt, aber nicht lang.
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab gerade keine Ahnung,
vielleicht 20 Spielstunden
in Battlefield 5 oder so.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, das war am Anfang ziemlich kaputt, ja.
Das stimmt, das haben sie nicht gespielt.
Der Typ ist aber nicht mehr da.
Das war der dümmste Marketing-Move aller Zeiten.
Den Leuten zu erzählen,
äh, wenn ihr's nicht mögt, dann
kauft es nicht.
Das war halt echt der komplette
Griff ins Klo.
Das find ich aber auch ein bisschen lächerlich, ne?
Wenn man sagt, wir machen jetzt hier Klo,
dann ist das ein bisschen lächerlich, ne?
Das ist ein bisschen lächerlich,
wenn man sagt, wir machen jetzt hier Klo,
dann ist das ein bisschen lächerlich, ne?
Wenn man sagt, wir machen jetzt hier Glorious Return
Battlefield zu seinen Wurzeln und
Zweiter Weltkrieg, und man hat keine Normandie-Geschichten drin.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, gibt es eigentlich
mittlerweile irgendwas an der Ostfront in
Battlefield 5?
Gibt's irgendwelche gekommene Geschichten
oder so?
Nee, siehst du?
Also, es ist eigentlich voll, voll für'n Arsch, ne?
Was ist Al-Sundan?
Irgendeine Map, die nicht gekommen ist, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das, die, die, die
Aussage war ja eh die geilste, ne?
Haben sie das nicht zu irgendwelchen Punkten
im Hauptmenü gesagt, die Technologie
ist nicht hier?
Zu was haben die das nochmal gesagt, die Technologie ist nicht hier?
Das war doch irgendwelche Anpassungen
im Menü, irgendwelche simplen Dinger.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was es war, wo sie dann
gesagt haben, ja, das liegt, die Technologie ist nicht
hier.
Die haben keine Tech für zweimal
XP.
Waffen ändern, Indien,
ich weiß, total sinnloses Zeug, auf jeden
Fall.
Okay, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Ich gebe ihm insgesamt
Recht, es gibt keinerlei,
und das kann ich jetzt nicht
eindrücklich genug sagen,
es gibt keinerlei Grund
2021,
sich Spiele vorzubestellen.
Das wissen die Hersteller
auch, deswegen versuchen sie
zusätzliche Pakete reinzupacken,
die man quasi nur exklusiv
fürs Vorbestellen bekommt, um das
irgendwie noch attraktiv zu machen, aber es gibt
keinen Grund, Spiele vorzubestellen.
Die Spiele sind,
das ist 90% e-Download.
Okay, bisschen viel.
70%,
70% Download, ja.
Es hatte
noch einen Sinn, zu
Xbox 360 Zeiten,
da habe ich mir Black Ops 1 vorbestellt,
bei einem Laden, bei uns
in der Ecke hier,
und habe das dann am Wochenende vor Release
abgeholt, ich konnte das schon am Samstag spielen,
da hatte
das Sinn gehabt, aber heute...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob es den Laden noch gibt,
wo ich Black Ops 1 vorbestellt habe.
Wartet mal.
Mal gucken, ob die auch Pleite sind.
Das Ding,
das Ding hieß wirklich so,
wo ich Black Ops 1
damals gekauft habe.
Kuschelmuschel, genau.
Nicht bei Softwarecom.
Reloaded?
So richtig
kleiner, kleiner,
genau der hier, so richtig
kleiner Furzladen gewesen.
Aber die waren halt noch voll dabei.
Ja, damals habe ich, da habe ich damals
Black Ops 1 vorbestellt, da habe ich
Samstag schon abgeholt.
Samstag morgens,
also 2010,
oder wann das war,
und habe das, ich habe ja schon Videos hochgeladen
vor dem Release am Dienstag.
Heute hätte ich da wahrscheinlich Instant Ban bekommen.
Aber ich gebe ihm, wie gesagt, voll und ganz
recht vorbestellt, ist absolut sinnlos.
Macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Okay, und jetzt lassen wir uns jubilen, endlich von Level Cap.
Wird immer Zeit hier.
Also der einzige Point ist eben der letzte.
Ja,
macht es nicht besser.
Gothenburg.
Ja, das finden
die Leute bestimmt
geil, dass sie aus
Gothenburg gekommen sind.
Okay,
das ist der geilste,
das ist der typische Level Cap
mit, der sagt jetzt zwei Minuten
im Prinzip in anderen Worten nochmal
das Nichtsagende aus dem Vlog-Post.
Big Brain, Big Brain.
Mir persönlich wäre es ja lieber,
so dockt da nicht so sehr drum herum,
weil man kann auch...
...
Corona-Hust wieder
Man kann es auch übertreiben man sollte sich auf ein gut spielbares Gameplay und Game konzentrieren und nicht das Gameplay permanent unterbrechen durch
30 Milliarden
Levolutions
Irgendwelche Sandstürme wo du nichts mehr siehst hier und da und sonst was es sollte eigentlich sagen wir so zu 80 prozenten ein relativ
gradliniges
Combat system sein mit halt
Der Battlefield Sandbox drumherum im Prinzip ist es dann halt doch nicht immer das gleiche dadurch
Und ja einstein alter ohne scheiß einsteig animationen müssen weg
Einst also Panzer einsteig animation ist der größte abfang überhaupt ich kann es eh nicht verstehen ich habe
Battlefield 5 kaum gespielt aber Battlefield 1 war es schon zu ätzend
Du hattest für alles
Irgendwelche komischen animationen du gehst du gehst an so ein Artillerieding animation du steigst in panzer ein
Animation wo es keine animationen gibt gab es dann für ins flugzeug spawnen und sowas total richtig nervig richtig nervig
Ich will einen panzer gehen und ich will einen knopf drücken und ich will in dem panzer sein und wenn ich sehe dass mich einer
Aimt mit seinem auto aim lock an lock und shit dann will ich im letzten moment aussteigen können weil ich ein gutes timing
Habe und es trotzdem überleben
So so sieht es aus
Ja das wird mich nicht wundern passt ja passt ja gut rein
Ja das haben wir das haben wir glaube ich alle gesehen auf
Auf twitter wurde viel darüber rumgeschrieben dass ein battlefield mobile game drin ist ganz ehrlich es ist nicht das erste
Aber die anderen bisher waren immer kacke kennt noch jemand battlefield 3 auf nintendo ds
Das hat wahrscheinlich schon jeder ignoriert aber wir haben es drehen ds
Bring ich das jetzt durcheinander also um 3 ds
Jaja es gab es gab es gab noch ein battlefield für ds oder bring ich oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander
Durcheinander oder war das call of duty kann auch sein dass es jetzt durcheinander
Moment
Was war das denn
Ach das war das iphone game sorry ich habe mich ich habe mich vertan das iphone game es gab ein battlefield 3 iphone game genau
Das war so der guckt euch das mal an
so schlecht
So sweets
zt so schlecht
Der legt einfach du hast immer nicht
Das ist garantiert von isch im china chinesen studio was das entwickelt hat
Das ist so schlecht
Das ist doch fake
Nein
Das gab es
Das ist, wenn du bettel viel auf wish kaufst das gab es wirklich
Heile extrem hohe fbs ja
Servers the game actually wouldn't be that bad
Because the graphics are nice only the blood sucks. Oh, that's my partner over there shit
If this was hardcore he was dead
Yeah, let's get him get him so schlecht
Oh, das ist so schlecht wie oh gott mobile games alter mobile games live commentary huge
Hätte ich damals auch machen sollen huge mobile mobile
Was exakt ist hier eigentlich very nice
Das ist so im arsch das spiel trailer. Okay, wir gucken ob es den trailer gibt gameplay trailer
Die grafik ist nicht schlecht, aber es funktioniert ja nicht
Das ist so schlecht
Hallo youtube möchte nicht mehr das video abspielen
Das hatten wir doch gerade schon das hatten wir doch gerade schon
Ich glaube das ist so schlecht dafür gab es noch nicht mal einen trailer
Es gab noch nicht mal einen trailer dafür
Ich glaube ich sollte das mal machen
Das ist aber super
Das ist die steuerung im touch screen ich kann es einfach nicht ab analog sticks mit einem touch screen zu simulieren
Gibt es irgendjemanden der der meinung ist das fühlt sich richtig an das fühlt sich einfach total
total
Es muss es muss irgendwie gehen an aber es fühlt sich nie also ich habe noch kein mobile game gespielt was analog sticks auf dem
Touchscreen simuliert hat was ich irgendwie gut gut gespielt hat
Man könnte einfach man könnte bei the way ich hätte mal einen tipp für die die das auf die das wirklich schon lange so haben wollen
Die könnten einfach auf dem pc spielen also wäre eine möglichkeit
Wirklichkeit also das einzige was ich davon mitbekommen gekriegt habe ist dass die leute jetzt
Keine fünf meter weit gucken können wenn sie mit dem fallschirm runterspringen und deswegen jetzt alle
Irgendwelche custom filter machen dass man wieder weiter gucken kann
Nein ich habe das event nicht mitgemacht
Ich habe das nur ein bisschen verfolgt auf twitch
Der ich auch glücklich
Was zum Teufel war das für ein schlecht animierter Move? Guckt euch das mal an.
Ach, der hat eben das Messer in den Kopf gesteckt. Das hab ich erst überhaupt nicht erkannt.
Ach, der schießt eben das Ballistik Knife in den Kopf und zieht es dann raus.
Das hab ich gar nicht erkannt. Okay, das war doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Also ich hab gehört, dass ganz viele Leute nach Skill-Based Matchmaking gefragt haben.
Das war ja der größte Wunsch der Spieler. Skill-Based Matchmaking. Und wir wissen, die richten sich immer nach dem, was die Spieler wollen.
Das ist auch immer geil. Reaffirm Commitment. So nach dem Motto, ich sag jetzt einfach jede Woche das gleiche.
Ah, Cheater zerstören das Spiel. Wir sind voll committed drauf gegen Cheater vorzugehen. Nächste Woche immer noch voller Cheater.
Drei Monate später. Wir sind selbstverständlich voll committed gegen Cheater vorzugehen. Ja, und?
Logitecher. Nee, Skill-Based Matchmaking ist schlecht für alle. Finde ich. Da kann man sich zuerst schreien.
Das Einzige, was Skill-Based Matchmaking bringt, ist, und das ist das, warum sie es auch machen meiner Ansicht nach,
ist Spielzeit erhöhen für Casual-Spieler. Ansonsten, finde ich, bringt das weder den Noobs was, weil die Noobs,
die merken den Unterschied doch gar nicht, ob sie Ultra-Tryharn für 50-50 oder 70-30 gebashed werden.
Du hast da ja keinen großen Unterschied dazwischen. Spieltechnisch wirst du es nicht merken.
Das Einzige, was sie damit schaffen, ist ein Anreiz, dass die Leute einen Ticken weniger genervt sind,
um damit die Durchschnittsspielzeit zu erhöhen. Weil wir sind die Leute, die das, wie ich, wenn mir ein Spiel gefällt,
acht Stunden am Tag grinden können. Das ist halt die Ausnahme. Die meisten Leute spielen vielleicht,
ich weiß nicht, müssen wir mal gucken, was die Durchschnittsspielzeit ist. Keine Ahnung, 45 Minuten, vielleicht eine Stunde.
Und wenn die dies erhöhen von 45 Minuten auf 90 Minuten, bedeutet das direkt für die wahrscheinlich rechnerisch doppelt so viele
Verkaufsmöglichkeiten für irgendwelche In-Game-Sachen.
Ansonsten haben da Noobs ja auch nichts davon. Noobs müssen mit Skill-Based Matchmaking genauso schwitzen wie sonst
und kriegen im Prinzip auch nicht merklich weniger auf den Sack. Also die merken das überhaupt nicht.
Und du merkst auch keinerlei Progression, ob du besser wirst. Das ist ja eigentlich das hauptsächliche Problem daran.
Ich hab an sich überhaupt kein Problem mit Skill-Based Matchmaking. Aber Skill-Based Matchmaking nur in einem Ranked-Modus.
Weil in einem Ranked-Modus hat das ja auch seine Daseinsberechtigung. In einem Rank hast du ja wenigstens den Rang dran stehen,
wenn du weißt, hey ich bin was weiß ich, Silber 2 oder Diamant 5 oder keine Ahnung, dann kannst du wenigstens sagen,
hey okay ich mach Ultra-Tryhard, sonst wie, aber ich bin wenigstens der und der Rang. Was du ja bei Public Matches überhaupt gar nicht hast.
Das juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Level Cap juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Juckt mich auch nicht. Juckt mich auch nicht.
Okay, genug. G-Baded hat er uns wieder. G-Baded. Nix Spannendes dabei.
Alter, die Yoshi-Musik.
So Leute, was gucken wir als nächstes? Seid mal her. Verklagen Sie Facebook. Natürlich. Direkt nach dem Aufstehen.
Kauft Spiele zum verdammten Vollpreis. Das ist ein Video von Maurice. Maurice guck ich gerne. Gucken wir uns mal eine Runde GameStar Video an.
Stimmt, das hat doch, äh warte mal, das war der Entwickler, welcher Typ war das nochmal? Ich hab's auf Twitter mitbekommen,
der gesagt hat, kauft euch die Spiele zum Vollpreis. Das war für irgendwie Playstation, Playstation, ach war das Days Gone?
Ja steht da, steht da sogar da. Wollte ich dir sagen, das war irgendein Playstation Spiel. Was ist das überhaupt für eine Aussage?
Kauft Spiele zum verdammten Vollpreis. Ich meine, ich entscheide doch nicht, ob das im Sale angeboten wird.
Und bin ich jetzt der Böse, wenn ich den Sale wahrnehme, den der Publisher oder wer auch immer für richtig hält?
Bei Key-Shops kann man sich noch drüber streiten. Key-Shops, die ihre Keys aus irgendwelchen komischen Quellen haben.
Nicht, dass ich jemals für so einen Shop Werbung gemacht hätte oder so. Aber da kann man sich ja noch drüber streiten.
Aber für irgendwelche anderen Sachen. Und außerdem auf der ganz anderen Seite, ich könnte auch sagen,
ja, bringt mal Spiele raus, die fertig sind. Bringt mal Spiele raus, die nicht 100GB Day One Patches haben.
Irgendwelche Sachen, die mich permanent dazu gibaden wollen, irgendwie mehr Geld auszugeben.
Also das kann man aus mehreren Perspektiven sehen. Mal gucken, was Maurice dazu zu sagen hat.
Wow.
CD Projekt Red fährt Rekordprofite dank Cyberpunk ein. Amazon stampft sein Herr der Ringe MMO ein.
Cyberpunk, aber auch nur, weil sich so viele pre-ordert haben.
Und ein wütender Entwickler fordert, dass ihr, ja ihr, gefälligst mehr Spiele zum Vollpreis kauft.
Das und mehr gibt's heute in den News. Also bleibt ein Weilchen und hört zu.
Ihr müsst auch gerne in die Kommentare schreiben.
Das und mehr gibt's heute in den News. Also bleibt ein Weilchen und hört zu. Ihr müsst auch keinen Vollpreis dafür zahlen.
Zum Thema Vollpreis zahlen. Ich hab mir den Heise Plus Abo geholt, weil ich einen Plus Artikel lesen wollte.
Und ich hatte im Profil keine Möglichkeit, Heise Plus zu kündigen.
Also bin ich voll ausgegangen. Okay, das wird automatisch auslaufen.
Und jetzt haben sie mir irgendwie, fragt mich nicht, 35€ für ein Jahr abgebucht.
Und ich hab da drauf geantwortet, hab ich gesagt, hä, wie, Moment, ich will das gar nicht.
Aber gut, für ein Jahr meinetwegen, aber kündigt das jetzt mal.
Ich hab nie eine Antwort drüber bekommen.
Jetzt hab ich ihnen einfach auf PayPal die Einzugserlaubnis widerrufen. Mal gucken, was passiert.
Ah, yes. Exzellent Gaming-Chair-Werbung.
Cyberpunk 2077 hat einen neuen Einnahmenrekord für Entwickler CD Projekt RED gesetzt.
Ja, weil so viele ihn gerade vorbestellt haben.
Nach 25 für die Firma 562 Millionen Euro.
Wo wird er dabei sein, nie was vorbestellt?
Der Switcher.
Tja, weil die Leute vorbestellt haben.
Ja, lustigerweise auch auf der Switch, was ich nicht verstehen kann.
Äh, ist das zu leise?
Stimmt.
Die war ganz gut. Die war durchaus okay, die Netflix-Serie, finde ich.
Aber wirklich top war sie nicht. Die war ganz okay.
Leider ein bisschen viel Logik-Fail dabei.
Das war halt richtig verschissen.
Die hatten ein Herr-der-Ringe-Online-Spiel?
Ich dachte, die wollten ein Herr-der-Ringe-Serie machen.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie ein Herr-der-Ringe-Online-Spiel geplant haben.
Ja, oder eine Entwicklung.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Die Chinesen!
Die Chinesen wieder!
Also, ich sag euch mal eins. Sollte New World... Lost World? New World heißt es, ne?
Sollte das floppen, dann ist es dicht mit Amazon Gaming Studios.
Dann ist es vorbei.
Crucible!
Aber immerhin haben sie die CryEngine geforkt.
Das muss man ihnen ja mal lassen.
Warum es auch ausgerechnet die CryEngine sein musste, verstehe ich bis heute nicht, aber Amazon.
Ich glaube, die sollten Crucible nochmal auf Stadia re-releasen.
Das wäre, glaube ich, die optimale Kombination.
Zwei Sachen, die keiner haben will zusammen.
So wie damals Nokia und Microsoft-Handys.
Das aber bereits mehrfach verschoben wurde.
Wenn ihr, wie viele andere, immer noch keine Playstation 5 ergattern konntet, dürfen diese Meldungen besonders schmerzen. Jede Menge anderer Spieler konnten sich eine sichern.
Und zwar genug, dass Sony damit in den USA den erfolgreichsten Konsolen-Launch aller Zeiten hingelegt haben soll.
Das behauptet zumindest die renommierte Analysefirma NPD. Sie stützt sich dabei auf Verkaufszahlen...
Was? NPD? Was haben die damit zu tun?
... aus dem amerikanischen Einzelhandel. Genaue Daten gab die Gruppe allerdings nicht bekannt.
Sie präzisierte jedoch, dass die Playstation 5 sowohl in Sachen Stückzahlen als auch in Sachen Dollar-Einnahmen die erfolgreichsten ersten fünf Monate...
Du hast durch den Preis-Champ eine PS5 gefunden. Nice.
Ihr stärkster Konkurrent ist aber überraschenderweise nicht die Xbox, sondern die Nintendo Switch.
Die sicherte sich im ersten Quartal 2001...
Ich dachte, wenn er jetzt Stadia sagt, dann...
... sondern die Nintendo Switch.
Dann hab ich gedacht, das kann nicht sein. Aber er sagt Switch, das ergibt Sinn.
Die sicherte sich im ersten Quartal 2021 schon wieder die Krone als meistverkaufte Konsole, weil sie aber billiger zu haben ist...
Irgendwie versteh ich's nicht so genau. Ich versteh's nicht. Ich versteh's bei der Switch nicht so genau.
Die Switch ist ein richtig geiles Konzept, aber es gibt kaum Games für die Switch.
Du hast da vielleicht eine Handvoll wirklich Must-Have-Titel?
Okay, es gibt mehr als die PS5. Für die Xbox Series gibt's ja im Prinzip auch noch so gut wie nix.
Aber es gibt ja eigentlich nix für die Switch.
Es gibt so fünf Must-Have-Titel, aber der Rest...
... dass sie einfach deutlich besser verfügbar ist als die Next-Gen-Konsolen von Sony und Microsoft.
Und auch besser als aktuelle PC-Spitzen-Hardware.
Insgesamt haben die Amerikaner dieses Jahr deutlich mehr Geld für Gaming-Hardware ausgegeben als im letzten Jahr.
Allein im März waren es 680 Millionen Dollar und damit 47% mehr als im März 2020.
Das brach den bisherigen Rekord von 552 Millionen im März 2008.
Völlig überraschend haben wir ein Lebenszeichen von Homeworld 3 erhalten, wenn auch ein recht verhaltenes.
Äh... War Homeworld nicht das Strategiespiel im Weltall?
Da war der erste Teil mega nice. War ja Homeworld nicht Strategie... Homeworld? Im Weltall?
Ja, genau das, das mein ich. Das ist Poggers gewesen, das Game. Also das erste.
Und es sah für die damalige Zeit auch mega gut aus. Das war richtig Poggers.
Die Entwickler haben eine neue Einheit vorgestellt und dazu sogar einen kurzen Ingame-Clip gezeigt.
In 28 Sekunden sehen wir, wie die Railgun-Frigatte ein feindliches Schiff malträtiert.
Für sich genommen ist die Szene recht unspektakulär, aber es handelt sich dabei um die erste In-Engine.
Wisst ihr, was ich daran immer beeindruckend finde?
Wie gut Spiele in der Erinnerung aussehen.
Also ich hätte sagen können... Hätte ich jetzt nicht gewusst, dass das Homeworld 3 ist.
Und irgendjemand hätte mir gesagt, das ist eine Szene aus Homeworld 1.
Hätte ich gesagt, ja klar, so sah Homeworld 1 aus.
Wahrscheinlich sah Homeworld 1 viel schlechter aus, aber in der Erinnerung sah das halt genau so aus.
Ok, sah schon schlechter aus. Es sah schon schlechter aus.
Vor allem die Auflösung ist nicht so.
Aber so viel schlechter jetzt auch nicht.
Also ich meine, so ein riesiger Unterschied ist jetzt auch nicht.
Gerade vom Hintergrund dazwischen.
Ok, ok, ok, ok.
Von nahm schon. Von nahm sieht es halt nicht gut aus.
Aber für die damalige Zeit war das wirklich cool.
Egal. Gucken wir mal.
Aber es handelt sich dabei um die erste In-Engine-Footage aus Homeworld 3.
Die Entwickler schreiben, dass aufwändigeres Marketingmaterial wie vollwertige In-Game-Trailer
noch ein wenig auf sich warten lassen wird.
Denn das wollen sie erst näher zum Launch und den Start bringen.
Wann kam das raus?
Wir werden also noch ein wenig auf Homeworld 3 warten müssen.
2000 oder so?
Ja 1999.
Wie etwa zum Design dieses neuen Schiffs geben.
Die Railgun-Frigate soll auf lange Distanz vernichtende Schäden anrichten können,
aber lange Aufladezeit haben.
Das macht sich rundbar gegen Angriffe aus kurzer Distanz.
Ok, Mark Helms da mal ganz im Ernst.
Ob das jetzt eine neue Einheit in Homeworld 3,
einen News-Slot rechtfertigt sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber gut, letztendlich können sie sich ja aussuchen, was sie wollen.
Erste Spieler-Feedback hin erklärten die Entwickler bereits,
dass sie das starke Wackeln bei der Aufladeanimation noch entfernen wollen.
Homeworld 3 übrigens von Blackbird Interactive.
Das war das Erste, was mich gestört hat.
Ich habe gesagt, ich kaufe mir dieses Spiel nicht,
wenn das wackelnde Aufladeanimation drin ist.
Allige Homeworld-Macher des ursprünglichen Entwicklers Relic
gründeten das Studio 2007 und sie brachten 2016 ein neues RTS
im Homeworld-Universum raus, Deserts of Karak.
Mit Homeworld 3 kehren sie jetzt zur Kernserie
und in den Weltraum zurück.
Wenn ihr ein Spiel liebt, kauft es zum verdammten Vollpreis,
fordert der Creative Director von Days Gone.
John Garvin ließ sich in einem Podcast-Interview
mit YouTuber David Jeff darüber aus,
dass Spieler heutzutage erst oft im Sale zuschlagen,
oder wenn ein Spiel bei Playstation Plus erscheint.
Wo ist das Problem?
Im Einwand von Jeff, dass Spieler ja aber vor dem Kauf
gar nicht wissen können, ob sie ein Spiel lieben werden,
erwiderte Garvin, könnt ihr auch nicht.
Aber ich sage nur, beschwert euch nicht,
wenn ein Spiel keine Fortsetzung kriegt,
wenn es zum Launch nicht unterstützt wurde.
God of War hat was weiß ich wie viele Millionen
zum Launch verkauft und Days Gone eben nicht.
Ja, das mag auch daran liegen, dass God of War
eben eine Hausnummer ist und Days...
What the fuck, was ist das für eine Logik, Alter?
Und es gab noch kein wirklich schlechtes God of War,
muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Ascension war jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn oder so,
aber God of War hat zumindest eine gewisse Reputation aufgebaut.
Man muss ja auch sagen, die haben sie ja auch echt erfüllt.
Das letzte God of War ist mega gut angekommen
und ist sicherlich immer noch eines der besten Spiele
für die Plattform.
Geile Logik.
Das Thema kam auf, weil Days Gone im April
Teil von Playstation Plus wurde.
Jeff fragte, ob das die aktiven Spielerzahlen erhöht habe,
aber laut Garvin sei das viel weniger wichtig
als ein Kauf zum Vollpreis.
Da kann doch der Spieler nichts für, Alter.
Was kann denn der Spieler für, dass die das jetzt
in Sale packen? Sollte der jetzt lieber sagen,
ich habe es mir jetzt nicht zum Vollpreis gekauft,
dann kaufe ich es mir gar nicht.
Talkwalk, danke schön für den Sub.
Damit würde man die Entwickler direkt unterstützen.
Erst kürzlich kam ans Licht, dass Days Gone
wohl keine Fortsetzung erhalten wird.
Game Director Jeff Ross enthüllte im gleichen Podcast...
Es mag aber auch daran liegen, ganz ehrlich,
dass es ein weiteres Open-World-Stells-Zombie-Abenteuer ist,
was mich jetzt persönlich überhaupt nicht anspricht.
Ich meine, ich habe die Konsole da,
ich hätte es mir kaufen können, es gibt es ja sogar für einen PC,
aber ganz ehrlich, weiteres postapokalyptisches
Open-World-Zombie-Stells juckt mich halt gar nicht, ja?
Dass er mal einen Pitch für Days Gone 2 gearbeitet hatte,
aber laut Journalist Jason Schreier hat Sony diesen abgelehnt.
Ross bestätigt diese Meldung später indirekt,
aber John Garvin hätte vermutlich sowieso nicht mehr dran gearbeitet,
denn er hat das Entwicklerstudio inzwischen verlassen
und gab im Laufe des Interviews zu, dass er gefeuert wurde,
weil er zu oft sein Temperament verlor.
Na dann.
Und zuletzt noch ein Hinweis in eigener Sache,
morgen startet wieder unser Find Your Next Game Programm.
Ja, ich glaube Days Gone soll für einen PC kommen.
Okay, das ist jetzt vorbei.
Ich glaube, das soll jetzt für einen PC kommen.
Also wer sowas mag, kann es ja zum Vollpreis kaufen.
Soll das jetzt nicht für einen PC kommen?
Ja, doch, hier.
Guck, ihr könnt das nochmal zum Vollpreis kaufen, Leute.
Jetzt endlich können das 50 Euro.
Gebt euch einen Ruck, kauft es zum Vollpreis.
Schnapper, ja.
Vielleicht haben die auch was dran gemacht.
Endlich zum Vollpreis kaufen, jawoll.
Ich bin schon ganz...
Ich hab schon drauf gewartet,
dass ich das endlich zum Vollpreis kaufen kann.
Oh man.
Ich bin schon ganz...
Ich hab schon drauf gewartet,
dass ich das endlich zum Vollpreis kaufen kann.
Oh man.
Kauft lieber Bitbattle zum Vollpreis.
Was kostet denn das?
Also das ist sein Game.
By the way, für Leute, die es nicht wissen hier.
Okay.
Making a Lego Domino Machine.
Ah ja, Big Brain, Lego Movies.
Nicht Lego Movies, Lego Clips.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Oh, darf man es überhaupt noch Lego nennen?
War das nicht, dass man besser Klemmbaustein sagt,
anstatt Lego?
Hast du dir durch YouTube
irgendwas krasses gekauft,
was du ohne niemals gekauft hättest?
Ja, mal das ganze Aufnahme-
und Streaming-Equipment-Zeug.
Ich hätte mir nie ein Audiointerface gekauft sonst.
Aber du meinst wahrscheinlich,
ob ich mir irgendwas krasses leisten konnte,
was ich mir schon immer leisten können wollte
und es jetzt durch YouTube möglich war.
Möglich wäre es wahrscheinlich,
aber ich hab mir da nichts Großartiges gekauft bisher.
Was ich schon immer mal wollte.
Ich bin eigentlich wunschlos glücklich aktuell.
Und ich würde mein Geld
auch nie irgendwie sinnloserweise
für Konsumstells ausgeben,
der dann nach einem Jahr wieder weg ist oder so.
Hast du früher mehr mit YouTube verdient?
Lustigerweise, ja, okay.
Wenn du die Zeit meinst,
wo ich gar nichts gemacht hab, natürlich.
Also ich hab früher sicherlich
mehr verdient mit YouTube als jetzt die letzten Jahre,
wo ich gar nichts gemacht hab.
War ja auch nicht schwer, wenn nix hochlädt, verdienst nix.
Aber aktuell, nein,
gerade jetzt, wenn man die Sachen
noch hier mitrechnet,
wenn man Twitch mitrechnet,
die aktuellen CPM auf YouTube,
plus irgendwie noch die ein oder anderen Sachen
wie mit Hetzner und so, ne, hab ich nicht.
Das liegt aber nicht,
ich muss das anders sagen,
das liegt nicht daran, dass ich jetzt irgendwie
mehr machen würde oder so.
Sonst liegt einfach daran, dass die Preise besser geworden sind
im Vergleich zu früher.
Früher war das so, da haben Leute ein 15 Minuten
Sellout-Video gemacht, weil sie eine 40-Euro-Maus
umsonst bekommen haben.
Und heute
ist es auf beiden Seiten
professioneller geworden, ja, also
die Leute auf YouTube wissen ungefähr,
was von ihnen erwartet wird, und die Hersteller wissen auch,
was sie erwartet.
Die Preise sind viel besser geworden als früher.
Oh, Massive!
Alter, das ist mal Big Prane,
ich muss noch mal angucken.
Das ist ja richtig Spock!
Also, das ist
Huge Prane-Idee.
Bist du jetzt Hetzner-Partner?
Ja, ich bin Hetzner-Partner.
Ich bin Hetzner-Partner,
also ich habe ja schon mal
ein Video gemacht,
und die Leute haben mir gesagt,
wir machen jetzt erst mal das Video
und gucken mal,
wie das so ankommt und was die Leute sagen
und wie wir da beide damit zufrieden sind.
Aber wir haben beide Seiten, also beide Seiten haben schon gesagt,
dass Hetzner und ich, dass wir eigentlich da interessiert sind,
längerfristig was zu machen.
Auch hier hauptsächlich auf Twitch
im Stream.
Es funktioniert.
Oh, es funktioniert.
Coggart.
Dofe Frage, aber was kann man mit so einem Cloud-Server machen?
Ja, wenn du beispielsweise eine Web-Anwendung
programmiert hast, kannst du dir darauf laufen lassen
und andere Leute können sie verwenden.
Wenn du
sowas nicht machen willst, kannst du zum
Beispiel
Location-Tracking machen für dich.
Unter anderem, das ist ein Zweck,
wofür ich aktuell einen Cloud-Server verwende.
Ich habe für
mobile Geräte, unter anderem
für mein iPhone mache ich
Presence-Detection und Location-Tracking darüber,
ohne, dass ich es über Google machen
müsste.
Das ist richtig
Big Brain.
Alter, hier, es wird
ja richtig advanced.
Ah, es hängt.
Es klemmt.
Wieso
5-Server für den Preis
jampt? Weil 5-Server
tatsächlich billiger sind als
ein großer. Ich habe
einen Analytics-Server, der aber keine
personenbezogenen Dinge lockt,
also ihr könnt die Anzeige stecken lassen,
einen Analytics-Server,
einen Frontend-Server
und 3
3-Crawler-Server.
Mit der Home-Assistant-App führt das
der NFC-Text aus.
Das ist ja richtig
Big Brain, das Ding, Alter. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
so was Simples, das ist ja
das wird ja richtig advanced hier.
Du kriegst mit
meinem Link kriegst du 20 Euro.
Moment, wir machen jetzt mal kurz. Ich will
ja,
ich will ja, dass die Statistik gut aussieht nächste Woche.
Wenn wir uns dann überlegen,
ob wir nicht vielleicht noch mehr zusammen machen. Also ich poste
euch jetzt mal meinen Link. Also wenn ihr auf der Suche
nach Cloud-Guthaben seid, äh,
ich wahnsinn, wenn ihr auf der Suche nach einem Cloud-
Anbieter seid und 20 Euro
Cloud-Guthaben abgreifen wollt,
dann
dann könnt ihr über meinen Link gehen
und euch den Account machen.
Und dann
müsst ihr das machen, was hier im Video unten steht.
Das da, müsst ihr dann
machen. Und
dann bekommt ihr 20 Euro Cloud-Guthaben.
Man muss sagen, 20 Euro Cloud-Guthaben
klingt jetzt erstmal nicht viel. Ihr könnt dafür
aber schon
die einen oder anderen Sachen laufen lassen.
Ich mein, der kleinste Server kostet 2,80 Euro
oder 2,90 Euro.
Fenster kaputt, ja.
Und ihr könnt also dafür
quasi drei Monate
einen mittelfetten Server betreiben
mit 20 Euro. So schlecht ist das gar nicht.
Also, lohnt sich auf jeden
Fall mal auszuprobieren.
Ihr müsst aber Neukunde sein.
Das ist korrekt, ja. Sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Funktioniert der Account? Ich hab keine Ahnung,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich denk mal,
du kriegst einfach 20 Guthaben auf dein Account
und Gutes. Ich hab keine Ahnung, für was das
alles funktioniert.
Boah!
Massive Idee
hier.
Ich find's immer geil, auf was für Ideen die Leute mit ihrem
Lego-Kram, sorry, mit ihrem Klemmbaustein-Kram
kommen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Aber es ist erst 11.44 Uhr.
Oh, jetzt
kommt hier Motorstelz,
Motorenstelz.
Lego-Anzeige
ist raus. Ja, aber Lego ist ja mittlerweile
geht das ja schnell.
Guck mal, da zieht sogar der Motor hinter sich her.
Dann hast du bitte gefrühstückt
vor
zwei
zweieinhalb Stunden, aber auch nicht wirklich
viel.
Da seht ihr mal,
wie anstrengend
Streamen ist, was du da für einen krassen
Kalorienverbrauch hast.
Oh, jetzt gibt's noch
Lenkungsstelz dabei.
Hast du dich schon mal mit Gaming unter Linux
beschäftigt? Ja,
genug, dass ich
es nicht weiter mich damit
auseinandersetze.
Also jahrelang schon, ja.
Und ich bin zu dem Schluss gekommen, die beste Kombination
ist ein Windows-House mit der Linux-VM.
Windows zum Spielen,
Linux für alles andere. Also
Linux für alles, was man nicht unter Windows machen will.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, jetzt kommen die
ersten und sagen, oh, das geht doch mittlerweile ganz
gut, aber warum sollte ich mich mit ganz gut
zufriedengeben, wenn's einfach funktioniert?
Nein, nein, nein, das funktioniert nicht so gut.
Man kann das theoretisch
machen, Windows-VM zum Spielen und Linux
raus für Produktivität. Kann man theoretisch
machen, aber das geht nur, wenn man
GPU-Pass-Through macht, da wird's schon ein bisschen
komplizierter. Dann hast du noch solche Dinge, wie
du brauchst einen zweiten Monitor, den du
anschließen musst, einen zweiten Tastatur, den du anschließen musst,
oder du machst irgendwelche Framebuffertricks,
dass du's doch im Fenster anzeigen lassen kannst.
Also, Windows-House-Linux-VM
ist viel, viel einfacher.
Warum fehlt bei der Katze Ecke vom Gesicht?
Monarch-S-Katze.
Boah, jetzt wird's aber hier aufgeladen.
Cute Reload-Animation.
Tactical Reload.
Nice.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Jetzt müsste man nur noch dort
irgendwas dran machen, wo man hier
in das Magazin automatisch
Steine so nachschießen würde.
Technischer Kundenservice ist schon mal mein Beileid.
Das Beste ist,
du probierst einfach ein bisschen aus, installier
deine Linux-VM und
bastel damit rum.
VM ist erstmal einfacher als richtige
Hardware. Kannste Snapshots machen und sowas.
Hast du auf der Arbeit auch Windows als
House? Nein, auf der Arbeit habe ich auf meinem Notebook
nur Windows, äh, nur, nur, nur Linux.
Da will ich ja auch nicht spielen.
Außer Super-Tux-Kart.
Das ist voll Big-Brain-Maschine.
Das ist richtig Pock.
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Was hätte länger gedauert,
das alles von Hand aufzustellen
oder eine Maschine zu bauen,
die das für ihn aufstellt.
Inklusive Laufzeit der Maschine.
Domino-Champ.
Geiles Zeug.
Es ist zwar irgendwie sinnlos,
aber die vielen coolen Sachen sind sinnlos.
Mit Slide-off-Hand-Doppel so schnell,
das könnte sein.
Battlefield 4 Top-Plays gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Also, was schauen wir uns das nächste an?
Ultra-Seamless Home-Automation-Ideas.
Den gucke ich immer gerne,
der hat wirklich gute Ideen für Heim-Automatisierung.
Nachdem ich ja auch mittlerweile schon
eine Weile im Home-Automation-Business bin,
gucke ich mir das immer gerne an.
Gucken wir mal, ob er ein paar gute Ideen diesmal hat.
Okay, habe ich bei mir auch, verwende ich nicht.
Ich habe ja auch im Badezimmer,
in der Küche,
im Badezimmer unten,
in der Küche oben,
habe ich ja auch so Dinger,
zum runter machen.
Die habe ich auch in meiner Heim-Automatisierung drinne,
aber ich lasse sie trotzdem immer auf.
Die gehen nämlich hinten raus,
da wird es auch nicht warm oder so.
Wozu soll ich die zu machen, wenn es eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt?
By the way, warum hat er eigentlich eine Mauer vor dem Fenster?
Exzellent, vielleicht ist er so im Keller.
Hey, was ist los? Ich bin Reed.
Ich habe über 30 Automationen in meinem neuen Haus gearbeitet,
und so far ist es ein ziemlich leckeres Fahrrad gewesen.
Das ist, weil die Automation...
Twitter.
Wo ist meine Werkzeugwand? Hier? Nein.
Wo ist die Werkzeugwand? Da ist die Werkzeugwand.
Guck mal, es ist schon ähnlich.
Es ist schon...
Es ist schon ähnlich.
Also die Löcher sind ein bisschen anders,
aber von der Technik her ist das ziemlich ähnlich.
Na dann, zeig mal her.
Lesen. Lesen in 2021.
Das glaube ich eben sogar.
Ja.
Okay, außer man hat eh schon eine Wand davor.
Ja, das passiert, wenn man einen Bewegungsmelder hat,
der direkt triggert.
Deswegen macht man da auch meistens irgendeine Art
Cooldown rein, dass das nicht passiert.
Das ist eine echt gute Idee.
Da kann man das nämlich ziemlich gut filtern.
Du sagst, okay, wenn Motion Detection ist in dem Raum,
dann machen wir das Licht an.
Wenn die nächste Motion Detection ist,
dann gucke ich für, wie lang ist das Licht schon an.
Und nur wenn das Licht seit über einer Minute an ist,
dann mache ich auch die Rollläden hoch.
Das ist eine clevere Idee.
By the way, deswegen mache ich diese Sache nicht in Home Assistant,
weil diese Java Template sonntags ist.
Okay, das fällt bei mir aus.
Wie willst du dich jetzt beschweren,
dass dir Hetzner mehr Geldgut geschrieben hat,
als ich geschrieben habe, oder was?
Schreib den Support an, ob du ihn 3,80 Euro zurück überweisen kannst.
Ja, das sind wahrscheinlich die Mehrwertsteuer,
dass sie sich da irgendwie vertan haben oder so.
Ja, das Problem habe ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Smart Doorbell.
Ich habe einen ESP32 dran an meiner Klingel,
der erkennt, wenn es klingelt.
Das reicht mir.
Das kann man machen, ja.
Das klingt gut.
Das ist übrigens oftmals das Problem,
was man mit der ganzen Heimautomatisierungsgeschichte hat.
Da habe ich mich auch schon teilweise verrannt.
Also du versuchst was zu basteln, was erstmal total einfach klingt.
Und dann stellst du fest, okay, das ist auch zu 95% der Zeit einfach,
außer es geht einer nach 22 Uhr in den Raum.
Außer es macht einer von Hand nach, keine Ahnung, um eine Nacht das Licht an.
Außer irgendwie es vergisst einer, den Fernseher auszumachen.
Außer das, außer das.
Also sprich, du hast 95%, wo alles gut ist,
aber die 5%, um das dann wirklich rund zu machen,
die sind oftmals ziemlich großer Aufwand.
Und auch Sachen, wo man gar nicht dran denkt.
Nein, ich bekomme keine 10 Euro, wenn ihr 10 Euro ausgibt.
Ihh, Ihh, sowas kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Kein Echo, kein Echo, Echo Dot oder sonst was.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, mach ich nicht, will ich nicht haben.
Okay, dazu brauchst du erstmal eine Smartwatch.
By the way, dafür, genau für das, was er hier zeigt,
da sind Android-Geräte top.
Da sind Android-Geräte top für.
Bei Apple kannst du halt nur exakt das machen,
was Apple sich so überlegt.
In dem Fall in Notifications auch nur Standbilder.
Wenn du jetzt wirklich ein Video anzeigen willst,
mit Android ist das kein Problem.
Du machst einen Tasker auf, der im Hintergrund
die Sachen entsperrt und deine Video-Player-App aufmacht.
Kein Ding, kannst du unter iOS halt vergessen.
Also wo man wieder sieht, es hat alles seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Ich weiß, andere Türböckchen können das von default machen, aber ich war glücklich, dass eine Automation dieses Problem für mich fixen kann.
Jetzt für die Laundry-Ruhre.
Ich dachte, ich könnte eine einfache Automation dazu geben, um mich zu helfen.
Aber ich war falsch, zu denken, dass Dinge einfach sein könnten.
Wie viele von euch erwähnten, brauche ich den Vent in meine Laundry-Ruhre zu automatisieren,
da mein Netzwerk-Equipment da ist.
Ich installiere den Smart-Switch, um an die Wascher oder Dryer zu starten.
Weil es eine einfache Automation ist, oder?
Nein, ich wurde wieder von meiner Familie verletzt.
Siehst du, die Automation hat funktioniert und die Switch aufgeschaltet, als die Laundry startete.
Aber jemand, es ist unklar, wer physisch den Switch aufgeschaltet hat,
nachdem die Automation losging.
Und ich war nicht wahnsinnig.
Eigentlich war ich beeindruckt.
Weil meine Familie mich auf die Automation verletzt.
Aber...
In Wirklichkeit hat er gesagt, Alter, lass doch mal die Finger von dem Schalter.
Ich habe eine Automation, die den Switch aufgeschaltet hat,
wenn es aufgeschaltet ist, als die Wascher oder Dryer startet.
Das ist übrigens auch wieder typische Kokona-Style, ne?
Das kannst du... Das sieht aus, das sieht aus wie Stein, ist es wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach eine typische Kokona-Holzwand.
Familie, nur Witz, ich liebe euch.
Ich habe auch eine Automation gemacht, die auf die Echoes anbietet, um die Wascher oder Dryer zu bewegen.
Aber ich wollte es nicht anstrengen, wenn jemand es bereits gemacht hat.
Also habe ich die Automation gezwickt, um nur zu sagen,
dass die Wascher oder Dryer noch nicht startete, 10 Minuten nach dem Schalter.
Du musst dein... Wie sagt man so schön heutzutage?
Du musst dein Twitch-Emote-Game absteppen.
Und die Basics machen diagonal skalieren.
Das geht halt nur Kokona-Styling, gerade wenn die Wand baut.
Das könnte ich bei mir gar nicht mehr machen.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir.
Das Dashboard ist cool, das gefällt mir.
Es ist ja auch brilliant, es ist quasi ein exzellentes Dashboard.
Für so etwas habe ich, also für genau so etwas,
habe ich an einer ähnlichen Stelle im Flur ein Fire HD 10 hängen,
wo ich mein Dashboard drauf habe, für ähnliche Sachen.
Da hat sich das Amazon Tablet gelohnt.
Das ist immer wichtig, man muss überall Cooldowns einbauen,
ansonsten dreht die Heimautomatisierung durch.
Du hast jetzt wieder einen Weg hergefunden.
Wenn du jetzt erst einen Weg hergefunden hast,
finde ich es schön, dass du den Weg her wieder gefunden hast.
Wie bist du hergekommen? Hast du auf Twitch eine Empfehlung gekriegt
oder bist du über YouTube hergekommen?
Aber wenn du schon da bist, ich habe gehört,
dass man einmal im Monat kostenlos subscriben kann mit einem Prime-Sub,
wenn man es mit seinem Amazon-Account verknüpft hat.
Sobald die Presence Detection sagt, dass keiner mehr im Haus ist,
fährt hier oben im Wohnzimmer der Staubsauger los.
Einzige, die verwirrt sein könnte, ist meine Katze.
CF0815, Dankeschön für den Sub.
NLCS, zweiter Monat.
Moment, Kinder haben kein Smartphone, was ist da los?
Ich dachte, heute hat man schon ab 5 oder so ein Smartphone.
Unter einem iPhone X geht da auch nichts.
Das ist eine saumäßig gute Idee.
Also wenn ich jetzt richtig verstanden habe, was er erzählt hat,
er hat gesagt, er hat Automatisierung am Start, aber es gibt Sonderfälle,
und die Sonderfälle sind die, die Probleme machen,
wo er die ausschalten muss.
Und er hat jetzt quasi was eingebaut,
was sich automatisch irgendwie resettert oder so.
Ach nee, wenn es, oder?
Ah, einmal am Tag geht das, das ist eine richtig gute Idee, das gefällt mir.
Oh, das Gametrain ist am Start, Leute.
Was hab ich hier, was hab ich übersehen?
Der guckt so, als will er gleich POG sagen, oder?
Der guckt richtig PORTSCHAEMP gerade.
Also NLCS, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das hatte ich schon, aber kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Wen haben wir noch?
Dr. Enfie, drei Monate, huge massive subscriptions hier wieder.
Und dann haben wir jetzt noch den Failor für 16 Monate, das ist ja schon...
Was war jetzt die Idee?
Dass er, wenn es Sonderfälle gibt, wie zum Beispiel, dass der Babysitter kommt
und seine Heimautomatisierung denkt, aber es sind alle weg,
weil er das anhand seiner Handys macht, hat er einen Schalter,
den kann er drücken, so nach dem Motto Babysitter,
und dann gehen gewisse Automatisierungen aus.
Und einmal am Tag, also morgens, resetten sich diese ganzen Automatisierungen wieder
und schalten es wieder automatisch ein.
Also er hat quasi so einen Schalter gebaut für Sonderausnahmen,
die er nicht quasi extra programmieren will.
Drückst du einfach den Knopf, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich habe die ersten beiden Subs übersehen.
Oh, ich gucke danach gleich mal.
Stimmt, der hat den Babysitter noch nicht wegautomatisiert.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Frage, weil die Kinder könnten auch
mit dem Staubsauger Roboter spielen, wozu den Babysitter?
Das ist eine gute Idee, der macht wirklich gute Videos in der Richtung.
So, okay, was, ich habe, ich habe Dings vergessen.
Moment, ich gucke jetzt mal Subscribers, Subscribers.
Also, wen haben wir denn hier?
Also, wir hatten ja alles subscribt heute.
Kann man das irgendwie filtern, dass man nur Subscriptions hat?
Alles klar.
Der Failor, Doktor Enfie, NRLCS, CF0815, Bockwurstler, Tokwok, Schulzi90,
Pzati, A91202, XhackYX, Stelzor, Quinn131, SaurusMaster, TomFMZ,
Per64, nee, das war vorgestern schon.
Exzellent.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs heute.
Huge, mega Hyper-Subscriptions hier alle.
Und eben noch der No Rules.
Zilent, exzellent.
Massive IQ Boost für den Chat wieder.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Ich könnte mich bei diesen Videos immer wegschmeißen, auch wenn wir das schon gesehen haben.
Okay, okay, die Katze, die Katze hittet gleich und es kommt irgendein Half-Life Anzugssounds,
sowas wie Major Fraction Detected oder sowas, 100%.
Ah, fast.
Moin Twinko.
Ich finde diese Sachen, die mit diesen Half-Life Sounds gedupt sind, finde ich immer richtig geil.
Exquisite, so habe ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen, Leute.
Außerdem, Leute, der Hype Train, noch 33 Sekunden, lasst euch mal von Twitch G-Baden euren Prime-Sub auszugeben.
Gibt euch mal einen Ruck.
Twitch braucht das Geld.
Überlegt euch mal, Amazon kann morgen keine Autos mehr zu euch schicken, wenn ihr nicht subscribt.
So noch 20 Sekunden.
Bei neuen Live hätten sie jetzt den Hot Button.
Kennt ihr mal noch den Hot Button?
Nee, nee.
Oh, einer noch.
Please.
Oh, oh.
Wie jetzt?
Ha, hat nicht mehr geklappt.
Der hat uns übrigens G-Baded, es waren vier Sekunden und auf einmal war er vorbei.
Das G-Bade, das stimmt nicht.
Es stimmt, Twitch hat G-Baded.
Es waren noch vier Sekunden und dann war er fertig auf einmal.
Richtig hart G-Baded, aber Kid kannte die, danke für den Sub.
Ja, genau, wir haben im Discord einen Heimautomatisierungs-Channel.
Ja.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Weiter geht's.
Gucken wir mal.
Ein Lockpicking-Lawyer, da geht immer.
Wir haben einen neuen GPU-Takt-Weltrekord aufgestellt mit AMD.
Okay, was schauen wir uns jetzt an?
Gucken wir uns jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt den Lockpicking-Lawyer mal kurz an.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt den Lockpicking-Lawyer mal kurz an.
Den Lockpicking-Lawyer mal kurz an.
Das geht immer nur zwei Minuten, das ist easy.
Der ist immer so leise.
Ach, das Modell, jetzt ist alles klar.
Wenn ich das Video jetzt schon sehe, der rüttelt einmal dran und es ist auf.
Wie immer, wie immer eigentlich.
Das ist ja la Lock.
Kaufe ich mir zu Weihnachten.
Okay, okay, er wackelt nicht einmal, er wackelt zweimal, das Video geht noch zu lang.
Alles klar, obvios, obvios.
Easy.
Easy, easy.
So, also was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Also wir haben zur Auswahl ein Freefall in jedem Call of Duty.
Alter 37, das können wir uns jetzt nicht angucken, 37 Minuten.
Ich hab Hunger, ich muss bald was essen gehen.
Boomer, Boomer essen, Alter.
Dann neuer CPU, GPU World Record.
Bot-Kommentare.
Oder?
Aber ansonsten noch.
Ernsthaft, wollen wir wirklich 37 Minuten Free-For-Alls gucken?
Okay, also wenn ihr wollt, wenn ihr wollt.
Ihr wisst, ich steige ja mich dann eh wieder rein.
Wie, ähm, nee, nee, siehst du, siehst du, wollen sie nicht.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Chat.
Chat, Bot.
Okay, dann gucken wir die Bot-Kommentare vorher.
Das geht nur 6 Minuten, das können wir uns vorher angucken.
Das Internet, der Ort, an dem die Welt wieder zum Dorf wird,
wie alle einen für seine Aufgabe unangemessen kleinen Bagger anfeuern
und regelmäßig von der Seite von verdächtig attraktiven Frauen angesprochen werden.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich in die Kommentare scrolle und ein Bot mit einem neuen Ansatz sehe,
wie ein echter Mensch...
Ich hab übrigens auch bei mir mittlerweile total viele Bot-Comments,
die posten, aber die sind offensichtlich, die Bot-Comments,
die posten immer irgendwelche komischen Seiten, so nach dem Motto,
this is a real dating site und der Account heißt dann irgendwie,
realdating.com oder irgendwie sowas total hängen gebliebenes Zeug.
Zu wirken ist das ein bisschen wie seinem Starter-Pokémon
bei der ersten Weiterentwicklung zuzusehen.
Und heute ist es wieder soweit, Carpator wird zu Garados
und wir alle haben eifrig mitgeholfen, ohne es zu merken.
Ja.
Lautstärke, please.
Die Geschichte der Kommentar-Bots auf YouTube ist lang.
Es gab die, die einfach stumpf ihre Links zu zwielichtigen Webseiten
in die Kommentare geblendet haben und es gab die, die versucht haben,
so auszusehen wie der Kanal, unter dessen Video sie kommentierten.
Dann kamen die Bots, die auf einen direkten Link oder Auftrag verzichteten
und stattdessen auf das Interesse der vorbeiscrollenden Pokerten.
Die kommentierten dann irgendwelche Timecodes und versannen diese
mit einem scheinbar zufällig ausgewählten...
Ja, die hab ich auch öfters.
...043 Dosenpfand.
Ja, genau, die hab ich auch öfters.
Der Trick bestand daraus, dass die Aufmerksamkeit auf den Namen
und das Profilbild des Bots gelenkt werden sollte
und die Leute dann erst auf dessen Kanalsite den Link finden.
Diese Bots waren...
Kennt ihr noch von früher,
kennt ihr noch von früher diese komischen, äh, diese, diese,
diese komischen G-Bate-Seiten?
So irgendwie bei 3000 Likes postet Lisa ein Nacktfoto und solche Dinger?
Das ist im Prinzip genau der gleiche Kram, bloß automatisiert.
Das mein, das, das gab's ja niemals, ne?
...Namen hierzulande aber ebenfalls leicht erkennen und dementsprechend löschbar,
weil sich die wenigsten von ihnen die Mühe machten,
wirklich auf die Sprache des Videos zu achten.
Sobald man dort also etwas Spanisches oder generisch Englisches las,
konnte man recht schnell hellhörig werden.
Diese Bots gibt es bis heute, haben aber in den letzten Monaten
ziemlich starke Konkurrenz bekommen.
Denn so genial wie es auch klingt, scheint es keine Bot-Armee
auf YouTube bisher versucht zu haben, aber...
Wo findet man denn die authentischsten und zum Video passendsten Kommentare?
Na klar, in den Kommentaren...
Äh, die authentischsten Kommentare, also die finde ich eigentlich immer
bei Montana Black Stream Highlights.
Also kopiert die neueste Generation an Bots einfach etwas,
das bereits unter dasselbe Video kommentiert wurde
und leistet somit häufig einen inhaltlich relevanten Beitrag zum Video,
der bei weitem nicht so leicht zu entlarven ist wie zuvor.
Das bedeutet, einige eurer Kommentare sind bereits von einem Bot kopiert
und wieder unter dasselbe...
Chat, was habt ihr mir da angestellt?
Ich mein, er deutet ja nicht auf mich, er deutet auf euch.
Was ist da wieder los?
Okay, das sind ja auch...
Also das, wenn das keine Bot-Namen sind...
Rektuget...
Tjongkafnr...
Und Zwiegpnsf...
Alles klar, so nennt man sich natürlich, ja.
Ich ignorier das einfach.
Einzige, was ich löche, sind Dinge, die komische Links zu komischen Seiten posten.
Der Rest juckt mich nicht.
Doch, doch, Duplicates kannst du relativ easy entdecken.
Doch, doch, das dürfte kein großartiges Problem sein.
Das kannst du wahrscheinlich relativ einfach erkennen, doch.
Berausgesetzt, YouTuber, das heißt,
wenn du ein Video kommentieren möchtest,
dann kannst du es einfach entdecken.
Und wenn du ein Video kommentieren möchtest,
Und wenn du ein Video kommentierst,
dann kannst du es einfach entdecken, doch.
Berausgesetzt, YouTube hat nen Komment-aapi,
aber haben sie bestimmt,
das sollte recht einfach sein.
Und wenn du es sogar halbwegs effizient machen willst,
speicherst du dir nen...
nen Haschwert zu jedem Komment,
und da kannst du sogar videoübergreifend relativ easy suchen,
ob das spam ist.
Funktioniert natürlich nur,
wenn die exakt das gleiche posten.
Sobald sich da was ändert, funktioniert's schon wieder nicht.
Also wenn die da eins hinten dran machen oder so,
dann müsste man wirklich den Text analysieren
und sagen, wie ähnlich sind sich die Texte
und wenn der Text zu 99% ähnlich ist
und sowas.
Ja, dann bauen wir!
Dann bauen wir!
Ich bin der Erste, der's ausprobiert dann. Easy.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier,
ich weiß ja, du bist hier
der Hacker-Man, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Plugin auf
mein YouTube-Channel loslassen soll, nicht, dass da noch irgendein Backdoor drin ist
oder so.
Aber es wäre vielleicht
gar nicht so schlecht, sowas zu basteln,
falls es das nicht schon gibt.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass es sowas
schon gibt, weil auf die Idee wären ja noch andere
gekommen zu sein.
Ich muss gestehen,
ich bin enttäuscht.
So viel Aufwand, so viel
Überzeugungsarbeit,
für das?
Aber das Witzige daran ist, jeder Bot
hat einen eigenen individuellen Link
zu dieser Seite und die sind schlicht durchnummeriert.
Und deswegen kann ich jetzt einfach mal mit meiner Sammlung angeben.
Also, ich hab die 2, 3,
5, 7,
8, 9,
10,
11,
2, 5,
7, 10, 14
und die 18. Die 1 ist bestimmt super selten,
wenn die jemand von euch hat. Ich hab die 3 doppelt,
also können wir die in der großen Pause tauschen.
Aber, ja, die Bots sind wahrscheinlich durchnummeriert,
um die Zugriffe, den Accounts und damit
ihrem einzigen wirklichen Unterscheidungsmerkmal
dem Profilbild zuordnen zu können.
So kann man sehr schnell herausfinden, welches Bild
am meisten Leute anlockt.
Aber das eigentliche Problem,
auf das diese Bots immer wieder aufmerksam machen,
ist den meisten wahrscheinlich nicht bewusst.
Im Dashboard keine Möglichkeit, Antworten
auf Kommentare nach oben zu sortieren.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Generell ist die Moderationsfähigkeit
von YouTube-Kommentaren
kaum vorhanden.
Es kommt immer wieder vor, dass Leute verwundert
sind, wenn ich auf ihren neuen Kommentar
unter einem alten Video antworte.
Aber im Dashboard sind die Kommentare
zu allen Videos standardmäßig
zusammen nach Neuigkeit sortiert.
Da landet also wirklich alles.
Außer die Antworten auf andere Kommentare.
Um also dafür zu sorgen, dass die Moderatorin
einer Kommentarsektion die Bot-Plage nicht aufhält,
posten viele Kopierbots ihre Kommentare
als Antwort auf einen anderen Kommentar.
Das hat zur Folge, dass dort Dialoge
entstehen, die direkt aus einem uralten,
surrealistischen Theaterstück stammen könnten.
Ich falle da immer durch.
040 die Schreibfehler?
Einmal versehen.
Aber YT in einem Hex-Code?
Unwahrscheinlich.
Aber auch den kann man
entgegenwirken. Man muss eben nur zusätzlich
einmal durch die eigentliche Kommentarsektion
scrollen und jeden einzelnen Kommentarbaum
aufklappen und schauen, ob dort nicht...
Das kann man bestimmt automatisch machen.
Also wenn YouTube eine ordentliche Comments-API hat,
geht das.
In allererster Linie
ist das nur ein weiteres Haar
in der Online-Suppe, das sich jedoch immer wieder
mit erstaunlicher Widerspenstigkeit wehrt,
wenn man es versucht herauszufischen.
Und wer weiß, vielleicht ist der beste Weg
gegen diese Bots, dass wir uns unter diesem Video
alle gegenseitig kopieren.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. In diesem Sinne,
und das ist fürchterlich schade.
Exquisite.
Ein Haar in der Suppe, das erinnert mich daran,
dass ich eigentlich essen gehen wollte. Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich hab erst...
Wobei, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Ich hab...
vor vier Stunden was gegessen.
Naja, gut. Es gibt Leute,
da hält das noch
vier Stunden, aber bei mir nicht.
Was denn das?
Ach, den wollte ich ja
auch mal machen. Der Gehaltspotentialrecht.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Das haben die erst seit zwei Tagen.
Da kann man seinen Jahresgehalt angeben.
Und man kann
das Bundesland angeben. Und dann kriegt man gesagt,
was man macht.
Also was man verdienen kann. Das machen wir jetzt mal schnell,
weil das ist easy. Also...
Branche meines Arbeitsgebers, Banken,
mein Bruttojahresgehalt, das weiß ich doch
aus dem Kopf wieder nicht. Das müssen wir jetzt wieder ausrechnen,
Leute. Weil ihr kennt mein Jahresgehalt
besser als ich.
Und wie heißt es? Tarif,
Tarifvertrag,
Versicherung.
Ja.
Das ist
zwar ohne Bonus und alles, weil so genau
darf ich es wahrscheinlich gar nicht sagen, aber
Gehalts,
Tarifvertrag ab dem Jahr, genau,
genau, okay.
So.
Das da.
Ja. Das, okay, das
kann man sich gut merken. 4321.
Also 4321
mal 14.
Okay.
Exquisite.
Alles klar. Dann können wir das jetzt mal da eintragen.
Also das ist jetzt, das stimmt ja
by the way nicht, weil das ist hochgerechnet auf
5 Tage und ohne Bonus und alles, aber das passt
schon. Ja, wir haben Glück,
wir kriegen 14 Monatsgelder.
Exquisite.
Okay. 60k.
Mein Alter,
36.
Yes.
Und?
Ich bin da.
Wie?
Das glaube ich nicht, dass ich mehr, so.
Geschlecht, männlich,
hallo?
Was ist das für eine Scheiß
Checkbox? Alter,
welcher Monarch S Webdesigner hat diese
Checkbox gemacht?
Man hat weiterhin
eine Checkbox drin, aber gecheckt wird da vorne.
Das ist
extrem Monarch S.
Bundesland,
Hessen.
Oh,
what?
Ausbildung?
Ja.
Wow.
Und Bundesland,
Hessen haben wir gemacht, oder?
Nee, Hessen.
Hä?
Wie kann man davon nur eins ver...
Man kann nur
einen Filter auswählen.
Was ist denn das für ein Stumpfsinn?
Warum kann ich da nur einen Filter machen?
Okay, das ist ja dumm.
Sucked.
Sucked, huge.
Warum ist das jetzt eigentlich so kaputt?
Okay, machen wir einfach mal Bundesdurchschnitt.
Darkreader, vielleicht geht es dann besser.
Nee, das liegt nicht am Darkreader.
Flashbang.
Blind.
Alter.
Wir haben sogar extra Flashbang-Emote dafür.
Ich sehe nichts mehr.
Na gut, also was sagt uns das Ganze?
Das sagt uns, dass der
Bundesdurchschnitt... Okay, wir gehen mal nach
Bundesland. Hessen ist glaube ich ein bisschen höher.
Genau, Hessen ist ein bisschen höher.
Also, sie sind hier.
Das sagt mir, dass ich quasi...
Der Durchschnitt ist...
Hä?
Was sagt mir das jetzt?
Warum kann man das denn anklicken?
Ich will wissen, was ist das hier?
Das hier sind garantiert nicht 66k.
66k wären da.
Was ist hier normal Bundesdurchschnitt?
Also quasi
55... Ja, hallo?
Warum kann man das denn anklicken?
Ja, ja, ich verstehe das schon, aber warum kann ich
nicht anklicken und sehe genau, was das hier bedeutet?
Wer hat sich das wieder ausgedacht?
Webdesign
of Doom.
Ja.
So, da kann man sich das jetzt...
Angeblich haben sie das anhand von Umfragen
mit über 200.000 Teilnehmern
oder was auch immer erstellt.
Ja, also, okay.
Das bedeutet...
Das bedeutet, am meisten werde ich
verdienen mit
und danach geht es
wieder runter.
Ja.
Warum genau sollte das danach runtergehen?
Weil ich... Die schmeißen mich dann
raus und dann kriege ich weniger, oder?
Midlife Crisis.
Midlife Crisis hat man eigentlich genau jetzt
so mit 36 irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Ich müsste jetzt eigentlich voll Crysis haben.
Crysis 3.
Huge joke, ich weiß.
Aber... Also, hier geht es
dann... 70 geht es hier hoch.
Okay, das ist irgendwie... Ist das so ein
Schwachsensrechner, Alter?
Okay, was bedeutet
Geilspotenzial? Ja, erstmal hier.
Wall of Text.
Okay, ich sag 250.000 Leute haben sie irgendwie befragt.
Big Brain, okay.
Was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt nicht Banken, sondern Versicherungen wäre?
Oh!
Na gut, Versicherung ist Außendienst. Kein Wunder, dass das hier runter geht.
Das machen die Leute nicht mehr, wenn sie so alt sind.
Zum Glück bin ich da.
Exzellent, jetzt weiß man.
So, vergleichen wir das jetzt mal mit
Frauen.
Oh, Grip.
Mit Männern. Bam.
Moment, hier kann ich 2 auswählen?
Verstehe nicht.
Ausbildung.
Kein Abschluss. Okay, wie gut...
Okay, das hätte mich jetzt nicht...
Das hätte mich jetzt nicht verwundert.
Dass man mit
keinem Abschluss...
Ja.
Okay.
Dann gehen wir mal
abgeschlossene Lehreausbildung.
Warum ist kein Abschluss
manchmal höher als
Lehre?
Warum ist kein Abschluss...
Warum hat kein Abschluss
mit 30
Verdienter im Durch...
Also ehrlich gesagt, nicht so wirklich vorstellen.
Es gibt bestimmt kaum Leute...
Ja, vielleicht.
Ich muss irgendwas auswählen.
Ich kann gar nichts auswählen, oder?
Okay, der Rechner
ist fail.
Das sind die Leute
am Höhepunkt ihrer Rapper-Karriere.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein, ja.
Metallindustrie.
Gut.
Der Rechner bringt mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so...
nicht so wirklich was.
Der ist ziemlich sinnlos.
Nee, nee.
Recht aussagenkräftig war das nicht, ja.
Aber überhaupt nicht aussagenkräftig
war richtig Pains-Champ der Rechner.
Total unsinnig.
Oh.
Blockchain.
Leute, ich geh essen, ich hab Hunger.
Mega Kohldampf.
Wie hast du deinen NFC-Text beschrieben
mit dem Laptop?
mit einer App auf dem iPhone?
Ist der Frazier online?
Schön, dass so viele heute am Start waren, übrigens.
Ah, Pool-Streams. Ich krieg wieder Pool-Streams empfohlen, Leute.
Hier, Pool-Streams.
Hab das gesehen?
Hab das hier eben gerade gesehen?
Pool-Streams sind wieder am Start.
Hier, Pool-Streams. 100%
Pool-Streams.
War doch klar, war doch klar.
Und die hier auch, die hier auch.
Pool-Streams.
Please, Twitch.
Twitch, please.
Bubba.
Oh, meine Güte.
Gutes Gameplay, ja.
Also gerade auf der Banane zu balancieren,
finde ich äußerst gutes Gameplay, ja.
Das ist halt mittlerweile so.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Wo kommen wir denn da hin,
wenn du einfach sagen könntest,
was du sagen willst?
So geht das nicht.
Bald kannst du dich nur noch über
Rauchzeichen unterhalten, weil du sonst was Falsches sagst
auf Twitch. Aber auf einer Bananereiten
im Swimmingpool ist selbstverständlich kein Problem.
Oh, Mann.
Naja, Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Also, wir sehen uns.
Halber Softporn Sonntagvormittag.
Ja, ist echt so. Deswegen wird Twitch da übrigens
auch keine eigene Kategorie für machen,
weil Twitch sich dann eingestehen müsste,
wenn sie eine eigene Kategorie machen,
dass sie einen eigenen Softcore-
Sub-Genre, Softcore-
Stream-Genre haben bei sich auf der
Plattform und das wollen sie nicht eingestehen.
Es gibt bald Pool-Streams vom Keks.
Naja, ich hab mich schon vorbereitet.
Also, wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Macht's gut.
TU!